we joked off camera about how sometimes
if you see a boom mic
in a film it's not the end of the world
and somehow it's almost endearing
because you feel like a
kind of a kinship or for me it's it's
just
it's not something i would want in my
own films and it's not necessarily
something i'm looking for in movies
but if i see it it doesn't bother me the
way it bothers some people
like some people i feel like they watch
a movie just to look for
little the mistakes whatever they might
be in the film
and i'm the opposite of that as a viewer
i
want to be involved in the movie i want
to be lost in the world of the movie
and so i'm also sometimes i'm almost
willing to overlook
things the errors of you know logic in
the screenplay
forget about boom mics you know if i'm
get taken away by a film and
that's kind of actually something i i
look for in movies and it's something i
try to do with my own
films too you know why do you think it's
it's almost endearing or maybe i'm just
putting that word into it i think it's
i think it's when i first started to see
it when i was a teenager or whatever
it just i noted it for what it was and i
just was amused
i was like that must be a low budget
movie or that was they didn't have time
to do that
and then you know once i started making
films and really dealing with those
those time and budgetary concerns and
knowing and learning more about other
people's work too
sometimes i'll see you know in a certain
film i'd see a dolly track and go oh
that's there because
they didn't have the time to redo that
take they didn't have the time
you know it was being rushed through
post or whatever and and i know that
because i know the backstory on these
things and i know how it can go
having you know now that i'm doing this
professionally
so it is kind of endearing to me it's
almost like you're seeing a little bit
of the world
a little bit of behind the scenes world
while you're watching the film at the
same time
right especially too in this new
instagram
sort of perfection era it's kind of nice
to see things that aren't that perfect
well that's why
that's why people myself included like
to watch movies from you know the 70s or
the 80s and even going up through into
the 90s i think
there's a certain point where cgi
became a bigger part of filmmaking and
then green screen became a big part of
it
and now it's almost like you don't trust
the images you're seeing
in any film in any you know especially
bigger budget movies you're not trusting
those crowds of extras you're not
trusting the location that they say it
is you're not trusting
the the action sequences you know how
much stunts were involved in that
because
you know that they could do it all in
post essentially
spend a lot of money and do it in post
as opposed to a movie like
say sorcerer which is one of my favorite
movies the william freaking movie
where you just know that they were in
the jungle with those trucks and they
had to deal with the realities of making
that
you know pulling off those scenes and it
just
i just think it's a different mental
effect it has on the audience
to know that somebody had to physically
make that stuff happen in front of the
camera even with it was with miniatures
or with rotoscoping or you know
this type of stuff like say they did
with the original star wars films
that's a whole different world than say
what people are doing
now with the same type of material you
know same type of genre
where it's just all cg and and
green screen so that's and that's
something my own work that i'm
i'm pretty i guess you could even say
militant about
i like to do practical effects
and you know all the time if i can
and if i have to use cg it's going to be
more to enhance what's there versus
build something out of nothing that's
interesting so yeah not trusting an
image so it's not just fake news but
fake images
yeah i mean and yeah because
everything's the tools have gotten
the technology's gotten so good and the
tools have gotten
into everybody's hands so that that's
just the the way people
make video you could say i guess you'd
probably say now because whether it's
television or movies or
short videos people are making that's
just the way people
do things and so it is harder to trust
what you're looking at uh you know in
not knowing like fantasy films but in
you know documentaries or you know
things that are positioning themselves
as is reality
i think it's harder to trust those type
of the images in those movies too
right like sherman's march versus i hate
to throw reality tv under the bus but
you know just something like that where
oh it's so raw well there's there's that
side and also if you know
like josephine i know it's it's funny
like there was a period where
there was a lot of interchange between
the movies we were making
you know the the features we were doing
in reality tv
and i would have actors you know that
that i directed that would then show up
in a reality series playing
roles and you know it that just
completely blows it out of the water
then we meet with friends who would tell
us stuff too that were they were working
on these shows they tell us how these
shows were essentially scripted and
everything was and
maybe the general public knows this
stuff now but
not to the degree still that insiders
know it
and so that just completely blows it out
of the water in terms of you know the
narratives that are being built on these
shows or
where these you know real people are
coming from
uh you know they're just actors looking
for a gig a lot of the times
so it's it just it just completely
changes your
your perception of those type of shows
you know
do you think people almost want to
believe that those people are real oh
yeah
they do they do they definitely want to
believe
that's otherwise why would they keep
coming back to watching it you know why
would the bachelor
still be on i mean it's absurd and
everyone knows it's absurd but people
still keep watching it
and i think a show like that
it's obvious more and more over time
it's become obvious that
the people who are on those shows maybe
in the first couple of seasons there was
a bit more like
you know actual real emotion there or a
real
idea of finding a guy or finding a girl
but i feel like now it's just a lot of
people who are the first thing they're
thinking about is promoting themselves
promoting their brand they've they've
got a song that they did that was a hit
somewhere
they've got this they've got that and
actually that's you know and i'm not
gonna
i'll admit we watch those shows too i'm
not gonna say i don't watch that stuff
we did
but we did stop watching it um
one of the reasons we stopped watching
them was because it was becoming more
and more obvious people were just there
to promote brands and to use as a
stepping stone to some kind of a
career as a host a tv host or something
like that and then you just i mean you
know it's not
real but then there's a whole nother
level of like fakery going on there and
you're just like okay i just
i can't i can't do i can't do it anymore
full disclosure i got um hooked into joe
millionaire when it first came out and i
had sworn off television
and it took me out of my my abstinence
so well sometimes
those type of shows can be fun you know
competition shows and reality shows like
i'm not going to say that i'm you know
immune to their
charms or sometimes that's what you want
if you've had a long day like you
you know you're just tired and you just
want to see some entertainment light
entertainment uh
i get it i really get it and you're
addictive too um
so i you know but yeah but there's a
under the surface there there is like
yeah there's a real uh
especially on the shows that are kind of
pushing for that like we've got people
from
the heartland who are want to make their
big break or we got people who want to
find love and you're like
really i you know it seems more and more
they just have brands to promote or
or something they want to use that tv
you know exposure to further
some kind of another agenda that they've
got
excellent excellent we made a whole
horror movie about that
oh you did we did oh let's talk about it
well it's it's fresh in my mind because
i was just talking about the other day
we
we did this movie called within the
woods which is a slasher film on paper
it's a slasher film it was a third part
of a series that i had
created called camp blood and the story
was like
i think it was five people they're in
there on this competition show they're
dropped into the woods where these
murders happened
and they've gotta uh stay the night they
gotta stay 24 hours
and without leaving they can't chicken
out and leave and otherwise
they'll lose you know they won't get the
million dollars anyone who stays there
at the end is gets a million dollars
so then it just becomes this you know
kind of like
people start getting bumped off for real
first people are getting scared by the
producers who engineered gags you know
to scare them off
then people start getting killed for
real and then of course the whole
mystery aspect of it is whodunit you
know which one of these people is
is the killer who wants to kill off all
the rest so they can win the million
dollars
and the reveal at the end was that the
character who did all the murders was
this female singer this sort of
kelly clarkson type you know wannabe who
uh had a cd and had a single and she's
just this is all she ever talks about
and she's obsessed with
and to her and her warped mind
becoming even if she had to kill people
and it was
out there she wanted to get fame she
wanted to get her name out there this
was her way to get her name out there
so the movie for us was it was a you
know continuing a series but for me
and for josephine it was a chance to do
something cool kind of
comment on this was in 2005 too when
reality shows were
really bigger survivor was a big one you
know these type of things were dropping
people in the middle of the woods
and let them you know let's see who the
winner is let's see who wins who makes
it to the end
and so we're kind of commenting on that
kind of stuff and on just people's
some people's just obsession with fame
and obsession to be recognized
for something even if they have to kill
for it
so that was the thing that that was sort
of the aspect of it that made me
excited about making the movie because
other than that you're making another
sequel
so it's all about trying to reinvent it
and find a way to make it interesting
for you
as a filmmaker do you think we're still
in that realm now where people are that
obsessed or it's even more interesting
i think it's worse i think it's worse
because because
when we made that movie like shows i
mean i think american idol was on
like i'm pretty sure it was but those
type of shows that are about like
people who want to be in entertainment
who are very obvious about that
there are way more of them now you know
you have the voice you have
the the song land that just came out you
have american idols reinvented and now
it's out again
there's other ones i'm probably not even
thinking of right now
it's i think that you know very american
sort of need to be acknowledged and
recognized and that's all been kind of
pushed up by social media of course too
that's that's that's taken hold and
created this environment too
but there are more shows like that now
than there were when we made
within the woods so i think it's gotten
worse yeah i think everybody
more people want their 15 minutes of
fame and they want more than 15 minutes
yeah andy warhol you're here 15 you know
it's now it's now
an hour and a half right they want an
hour and a half they don't small they
want a series you know they want
they want uh you know a career out of it
they don't just want 15 minutes they
want a career
so and you know you wonder how many of
these people are out there well plenty
because these shows keep going and they
and people keep watching it too so
you know do you think there are people
in entertainment though that also just
want to create
stuff that they want to watch it's not
well absolutely
i mean i'm i'm one of those people and a
lot of i know a lot of people like that
who want to create stuff that they want
to watch i mean you and a lot of times
that's that's where our movies come from
when we talk about what movie we want to
make or what movie we
want to consider trying to get uh you
know get off the ground
it's literally if i don't you know if i
want this
if i want to see this movie i'm going to
make this movie you know that's that's
how a lot of our projects have started
is is not with someone giving you the
green light giving yourself the green
light
and and making something that you
otherwise it's a real cool feeling to to
when you get to the end of that process
if you
you know if it goes that far to be like
this movie wouldn't exist if it wasn't
for us
like if we hadn't you know come up with
this idea and nurtured it and built it
and
worked on it for years it wouldn't exist
because there's plenty of movies out
there that exist
independently of many of the people who
work on them
which would be like most studio movies
like today that'd be like all studio
movies
my opinion um you know
you grew up in virginia yes so you were
exposed to sort of the all-american
as pretty much as all-american as you
can get yeah yeah i mean i grew up in
suburban you know suburban neighborhoods
and you know literally it was almost
like the stranger things
sort of upbringing you know me and my
friends riding our bikes around you know
getting into trouble you know that kind
of stuff and the playing video games and
hanging out
and reading comic books and somewhere
along the line
i sort of took my love of storytelling
and reading and
writing i sort of took that to the next
level and started
you know i got my first high video
camera so
what did you make the first actually the
first short i ever made is sort of lost
now but it was called the beast in the
basement
and that was started as a school project
i was in
how old was i when i did that i mean it
was before
i was living in georgia i mean i'm
probably 13
12 or 13 years old something like that
and
i remember the teacher i don't remember
what she wanted us to do but it wasn't
that
i changed it over to that was probably
supposed to deliver a paper about
something we're interested and i said
can i make a short instead can i make a
movie instead
and so we made this short with me and my
friend and uh my dad
shot it my dad was the the dp on it and
we got a camera from somebody i think it
was a friend of his who had cause i even
own a camera at that point
our family didn't it was i did not grow
up with like super eight films or video
cameras in the house
nobody had that i was the one who wanted
that so we had to borrow a camera from
somebody
and my dad shot it and it was like a mad
scientist
creature kind of thing in the basement a
beast in the basement
and we just did it in like a day or two
and and showed to the class and
everybody enjoyed it
so so that i continued to
to do things along those lines but my
dad was my dad never shot anything from
me ever again
i remember he started getting creative
with some of the dutch angles and i was
like
all right dad i don't know if i want
dutch angle for that shot
so you know so having grown up with this
american experience
though and you said just previously that
it's sort of the american way you have
to be known for something
do you see maybe in the the european way
or another way where it's more about
the art of it the love of it creating
something can you think you think that
can be
possible in the american experience or
it has to be about you've got to do the
ted talk you've got to make sure that
it's
out there you're recognized i think that
the
the publicity nowadays
has superseded the content in terms of
you know i'm talking about film people
artists
anybody really i unfortunately i think
people are spending way more time doing
pr
and finding new ways to get them you
know whether it's twitter or social
media whatever they're doing
there's a lot of putting the cart before
the horse nowadays that i see
i see it with younger people and i see
it with older people i mean it's not
with it's like one generation is
just doing that and nobody else is i
think there's a lot of that going on
part of it is because this the times we
live in you do have to cut through the
noise and you do have to find ways to
get your name out there
and getting your work out there that's
harder than it used to be
and you don't have as many people
cheerleading for you or let's just say
invested in you because frankly because
they're going to make money too
like you used to so you have to do more
of the work yourself and you have to
find more ways to
kind of spread it around in terms of
that turning into like creating a
monster where you've got people who are
just
completely about the exposure and not
about doing any
actual work yeah there are people like
that you know i mean i'm
i don't think i'm one of those people
and i try to not associate with people
like that
but there are a lot of people like that
and sometimes they do get more attention
than
than me or other people who are just
more like let's do the work let's do a
good job let's make sure this thing is
really
as good as it can be the movie you know
before we release it
let's you know you know i think
sometimes there's people that are
blowing through things really quick and
and not thinking about you know the end
result
it's more about just getting your voice
out there and
being louder than everybody else you
know
so a european i don't know if you you
know i think
it is more of an american thing than a
european thing for sure
um yeah that being said though social
media is
necessary especially in the independent
space if you don't have money
yeah oh yeah that's why it's assumed
such an important
great importance especially the
independent everywhere really but i mean
the independent
world yeah it's it's it's assumed much
more of a
importance than it that say it used to
have because the infrastructure is so
shaky and and minimalized from what it
used to be and it was never easy
i don't want to give the impression it
was ever easy to make independent movies
because it's
it was not um for me or anybody
but it has
you know taken a great it's taken on a
greater role because of that
because the the infrastructure to
support you is not there as much as it
used to be
i'm talking about distributors and you
know
um you know theatrical play reviews
um you know big uh brick and mortar
stores
you know foreign sales things that used
to boost the impact of your film boost
your profile
and you didn't have anything to do with
it i come i've been doing this long
enough that that's how it was when i
started
right blockbuster the little section
that had all the cool indie films like
there would be 25 of one movie that i'd
be like okay i know i don't want to see
that one yeah yeah
but where's like the weird like indie
ones and it was such a treasure
yeah to find out yeah yeah all those
stores yeah i mean
except for one and that was yeah that
was a huge that was a huge
um goal actually back then was getting
your movie into blockbuster
and a lot of us didn't succeed in that i
got a few movies in the blockbuster
but it was after making i don't know
let's say i probably directed 10 movies
before i got a movie in the blockbuster
oh wow
and these are all distributed by the way
commercially distributed
but you know you get your hollywood
video was sort of the the one that would
take
more indie films they were more indie
friendly blockbuster was like the big
you know house on the hill with the big
gates that
you know they wouldn't open for anyone
except the studios so it was very tough
to get a
an indie title into blockbuster back
then
do you remember walking in there and
finally seeing it yeah yeah oh yeah yeah
i mean the movie i got in was called
death factory and it was
no of course it was a thrill to see it
on the shelf to see on the new release
wall
i remember sometimes i would just we'd
go in my wife and i would go into
rent movies and then i'd always sort of
want to see how my
my titles were doing you know like do
they rent or sometimes you even see
people staying there looking at it and
considering whether to rent it or not
so you have to restrain yourself oh yeah
it's great you should get that move you
should rent that
um yeah that was that was like that's
something that
today's filmmakers on they will never
have that experience
you know independent filmmakers won't
have that experience to walk into a
store that was a store that they had
gone in as a customer
as a fan and then see their own movie on
the shelf i
i can't describe the thrill of that you
know it's
you know i wish i'd taken photos back
then because i didn't because i thought
that was gonna go on forever
i never thought no i mean i didn't think
video stores were gonna
like go out of business the way they did
but you know
you never know right there's always some
change and netflix came
in and then sort of eroded that after a
while but
but when it was happening i mean no no
none of us and none of us have photos of
that in general because we didn't think
that was gonna
why would you want to take a picture of
that there was no iphone see well yeah
that's the thing too it would be
taking that picture on film probably
back then polaroid
or at least yeah the polaroid or or
something yeah so it was
but anyway yeah it was a big thrill to
see on the shelf
for sure what was your first job in film
and television when you got to los
angeles
the first movie job i ever had was on a
movie called kiss the girls
uh which was um this paramount movie
i worked on in 96 summer of 96. it was
between my third and fourth year of film
school
and the director that was gary fleeter
who was from my hometown and i knew him
and he also went to boston university
where i went to film school so we had
those two things in common and i didn't
i had gotten in touch with gary
a little bit before that just wrote him
a letter saying i'm you know miss young
i'm a film student young filmmaker from
virginia beach and all this and he had
actually gotten back to me and
and been very encouraging and he
actually told me
i'm gonna be making this movie you know
this little movie with morgan freeman
uh and would you like to work on that so
it was perfect timing because it was you
know the summer
and i was able to work on that was
essentially an internship
for school but it was like a real
working internship because i got to see
for uh i worked on it for about two
months two and a half months
and just see the whole inner workings of
a movie in a big movie too
you know a 35 million dollar movie
and it was just it was just a very cool
experience gary was great to
give me that opportunity and i learned
i learned a lot about i would say things
that i
think are good and also bad um in terms
of the wastefulness sometimes the big
studios
and you know the sort of the standing
around and
not not much going on um
but it was just such an invaluable
experience just to see like
you know how the how movies are made the
paramount lot all of that
so it was just a really cool and i loved
being on set
that was something i learned i had made
shorts and
even features with my friends on video
up to that point
but it was the first time i've been on a
professional movie set and i just love
the
atmosphere the set with the bustling
crew
and all the things that go on you know i
enjoyed it a lot
i think i rented that movie at
blockbuster no i can remember that was a
that was a hit movie yeah
morgan freeman and ashley judge right
you see them on the side yeah exactly i
mean they were they were both really
cool i'm proud to buy a birthday present
from morgan freeman at one point they
said go go get a birthday present for
morgan freeman and i said well what does
he like
he likes boats big on boating so i
bought him a book about boats
and the other thing i remembered about
ashley judd and she was pretty new back
then
it was one of her maybe her first big
movie is she baked brownies for the pas
she was super nice she brought i had
somebody bring ice cream down one time
like a
cart like a haagen-dazs cart like just
ice cream for everyone the crew oh cool
i mean she was really cool and um
i mean franco was a lot of cool people
you know it was a lot of cool people on
the film and
it was a great introduction to la for me
because i'd never even i mean i think
i'd been out here once
prior to that just visiting a friend for
like a week
and every day you're going to a
different location
and it was kind of funny because my dad
came out here with me at first you know
it helped me move into this
apartment i was like renting a room in
this apartment in the valley
and he's like well i'm gonna we'll go
we'll go to location like
you know because we got the call sheet
you know he's like we'll go over the
location the day before
so you know where to go and how to get
there he's just trying to help you know
and we did go to the location which was
a hospital and an abandoned hospital in
downtown or something
well that was great for the first day
maybe second day but then we had a
company move
and then we did another company so
basically i was
you know i had a crash course in la
freeways
and directions and using this is in 96
so you know no gps
you know using the thomas guide and the
call sheets and the directions they
would give you those little maps
and sometimes i went you know i messed
up i always made it to set every day
on time relatively on time
so because they couldn't start it
without be you know
uh but it was it was a real learning
experience yeah
how soon after that did you make a full
move or that room in that apartment was
your full move
that was no i was just there for the
summer in fact i should probably mention
the other
flip side of that the other experience i
had was i worked at scot-free
productions ridley scott's company after
kiss the girls that same summer i
interned over there as a script reader
for about a month month and a half and
that was interesting it was like going
from the state you know the set work
every day you're a new location you're
in the woods you're in wherever the
beach
and then to being an office in beverly
hills every day air-conditioned with you
know kearns nectar's up there for
everybody to take
and you know i have to say nice people
really nice people i learned a lot but i
was so much more a fan of being on set
that was something i discovered about
myself that summer for sure in terms of
what direction i wanted to go
in the movie business i didn't move out
here until the following summer
97 and that was right after graduation
and i had a job lined up literally
once again got a call from another
director to work on a movie
which i was fortunate to to be able to
do
so quickly you know so then once i moved
out here in the summer of 97 i stayed
and that's
been here ever since i think that's such
a valuable thing for people at a young
age to know
either they're not the office guy or
they're not
the i'm going to be out there yeah see
to my pants trying to figure stuff out
yeah it was i mean it was just i'm
because i
my favorite part of filmmaking is the
shoot that's never changed whether i was
a teenager or
now and being in an office
it was interesting to read scripts and i
remember reading a lot of scripts while
i was there i read you know the first
time i ever read a tarantino script on
the on the page first time i read a
kevin williamson script
first time i read um i don't know they
had a bunch of interesting things over
there
you know and things they were not
necessarily the things they were making
because they weren't making as much
stuff as they do now
they're making like a movie a year back
then um
now they're like huge you know they've
got tv shows and movies running all the
time
but it was it was just yeah development
was not really my
thing not because i i love reading and i
love writing
um and i came into this into film as a
writer
you know more than a director initially
but i just enjoy the set experience this
sort of you know adventure
of of being on set more
did you have a car when you first came
to l.a i did
yeah you had a car in fact my dad and i
drove cross country
from virginia oh wow that summer we
drove
well that was an adventure too you know
uh we drove cross country kind of
followed almost like the old route 66
uh at least for part of it and it took
about a week i think for us to drive it
or maybe less than a week i was like
four days but anyway we
we drove out here and i had a yeah i had
a car
gotta have a car you know especially on
that
on kiss the girls i mean you're uh you
know driving to one day you're driving
to el segundo one day you're driving to
the malibu one day you're driving to
you know santa clarita
right did it almost spoil things for you
because you know when you have a really
great first experience with something
then you think everything else like
that's going to be like that
and and some sets are amazing and
everybody gets along and it's like a
very special experience
yeah and then others it's actually not
that way
well i have to tell you the two movies i
worked on after that were much more
special experiences for me
and they were lower budget movies they
were more like in the million dollar
range
per movie uh because the first two films
i worked on out here was a movie called
spoiler was a sci-fi
action movie and then the next movie was
actually filmed in romania
and that was a kids movie kind of a
kid's horror movie
and these were you know low budget films
direct-to-video movies
made you know mostly under one roof like
i remember the spoiler was filmed
entirely in burbank
und in this stage it used to be an old
warehouse or something and they shot
three movies there in a row
they just switched out the walls
repainted certain parts of it they shot
three movies in a row
and our movie was the third movie um and
i remember when they had a wrap party
they had a wrap party for all three
producers the producers didn't feel like
springing for three wrap parties so we
just had one
it was a big wrap party i met a lot of
people at that wrap party
and then the one in romania was even
lower budget and it was like the most
fun thing i'd ever
most fun i ever had in my life you know
so the big budget
thing you know the paramount thing was a
great learning experience
but it was it didn't have that sense of
fun and sense of
um creativity and i should also bring up
very importantly that on
spoiler i was able to direct second unit
as a you know 22 year old
recent film school grad i had was given
a designated dp ac
and 35 millimeter panavision camera and
i was allowed to direct second unit
on this movie so you know that's
something that
that surely wouldn't have happened i
kissed the girls and that was because of
the director i was working with and he
was just a super nice guy
jeff burr who put me under his wing and
and you know brought me onto these films
so i guess the lesson from that might be
that you know the lower budget movies
you learn more you get to do more you
get to have more
creative input sometimes into things
and you get to know everybody a bit more
too because there's not as many people
working
you know there aren't like maybe there's
50 people working versus 100 or 200 or
something like that
you know so all great experiences though
you know at what point did you say you
were
not done working on sets for other
people but you wanted to be
driving your own film your own content
you know i never had a specific point
where i stopped in fact
the first directing writing directing
job i got
was so low paid that i didn't stop doing
those those set jobs um
it was a movie called scream queen and
and i was thrilled to get the
opportunity to write and direct but
you know almost immediately after that i
went back to doing i was doing special
effects assistant work and production
assistant work and stuff like that so i
kept
doing that but and that kind of went on
a little bit like that for a year or two
but you know what's interesting about
that is
on those bigger films that i was paying
on or doing special effects i met a lot
of people
i met a lot of professional good people
effects
artists and you know camera people and
all this kind of thing
so that my movies when i started to get
to direct
more and more i was able to bring them
on to those films or at least consult
with them and they would like say
recommend an intern who was really good
or something like that so
i think that was a really good thing and
it's something that i always i still
believe in now that people should
who want to get in the business and you
know everybody wants to direct and
everybody can't wait to direct but
it's really really good to work
on other positions you know in other
departments
and learn from those departments and
learn from that experience and see how
sets are run and see what works and what
doesn't work what you like and don't
like and also you will meet people
and and those people will be the people
you work with or you call favors from
when you do
direct a short or a feature
so that's that's kind of how it happened
for me now screen queens that's
i remember rhonda shearer used to do the
usa up all night
and show like movies like yeah yeah that
was just some really
just fascinating i know a lot of the
people who made those movies
i'm very i'm no that's that's no i used
to watch that show too
it was fun i enjoyed it yeah she was a
great host okay well the scream queen
had this actress named linnea quigley
yes who's okay so you know who she is
well she was the star of our movie
and um once again i i our movie wasn't
really
it was a very modest film but because i
had worked on other stuff and i knew
other you know new people
i was able to call in a favor at least
from a friend and say hey would you
i know you know linnea would you be
willing to tell any about this movie
we're trying to make and would she be
willing to read the script and that's
how we got the script to her and i met
with her
had a great sit-down meeting with her
and you know when she was she was in
it was not a huge time commitment for
her and we also
sort of repaid the favor by shooting a
music video for a song that she had done
at the time she had a song called this
chainsaw is made for cutting
it was sort of the nancy sinatra you
know kind of like that so we did the
you know so she acted in our movie for a
couple of days we did a music video for
her
and you know we had fun doing it and of
course for me it was really cool to work
with her but yeah she was in a lot of
those type of films she is a scream
queen she's a major screen queen and
that's why she was in the movie in the
first place was
it was sort of a self-referencing kind
of a
hollywood on hollywood movie you know
that was that was the idea with that one
so we were really it was really cool to
have her in the film it was a good start
for
for me at what point did
the stakes rise for you with making
films where you had
money that was given to you and it
became more serious and then it became
more stressful
at times because now you're responsible
for more and how did you handle that
i think that one of the movies that that
happened
for me on was a movie i did called
demon's kiss which was
uh well it was a bigger it was the
biggest budget i've had till that point
i probably directed
five or six movies to that point and
demon's kiss was a bigger budget it was
shot on film
that's right off the bat that's puts you
in another
bracket economically you know and it was
a longer schedule
and it was just a bigger film and it was
the first film i was making for this
particular company
and i was i think this
and also it was a script that i had it
was a concept i had pitched
to the investor which i should point out
that
a lot of the films were made back then
especially horror films and exploitation
films and stuff
sometimes someone would just come to you
or they come to the producer you're
working with and say we want to make
this movie x movie and are you in are
you out
they already had a title they had
artwork they'd already done pre-sales in
milan or something and they it was your
choice whether you wanted to be involved
in the movie or not
demon's kiss was something i pitched i
had the title
the concept and i pitched it and it got
the green light
so and i was writing it and directing it
so i was i was very
it was very important to me not only to
handle the you know the production well
and and you know come in on budget and
you know that was but to make a good
movie that i'd be happy with too
uh because i was actually getting more
resources to do it with
you know uh that was that was one of the
films i think for sure
that i was you know and it wasn't i
can't say i had fun making that movie
you know i mean i've made movies what i
a lot of times say is the movies i've
had
the most fun making they didn't turn out
as well or they didn't do as well
some of the ones that have been
nightmares to make they
they're like my most my most successful
films
you know i it's i don't know why exactly
that is sometimes
because i work hard on everything i
direct but it just turns out that way
sometimes
demon's kiss was a was a really hard
movie to make it wasn't a huge
pit necessarily but it wasn't you know
didn't disappear either it's kind of
somewhere in the middle
but i just remember every day on that
talking about a different location every
day
i had two dps i had a dp who was forced
on the production who was
more or less trying to take over the
movie um
i had to take him aside
early on and tell him that that's not
going to happen that's not going to work
and
and after that he was fine but that was
something i had to contend with
on the first day of shooting wow there
was a lot of
nudity in the film it was an erotic
thriller
and it was the most of those type of
scenes i've ever ever had to direct at
that point so
thankfully the actors are really cool
and professional and all that but that
was kind of a challenge for me too
and i just you know just the
post-production was also very
challenging
let's just say in terms of the movie i
saw it being versus what the
executive producer saw it as being
but yeah that was probably one of the
first times i remember feeling and i
just got
married too so it was like it was first
movie i made after i got married and and
we've been prepping it for a long time
so you know you know the more prep you
have sometimes the more psyched out you
can get
that's why i don't like to have too much
prep on a film i like to have some but
not too much because then after a while
you can start to
psych yourself out a bit
that's really interesting the the ones
that didn't turn out the best actually
were the most fun and then
vice versa that's weird i mean like for
example i mentioned this movie death
factory that had in blockbuster my first
one being blockbuster okay that was a
nightmare to make that movie
we were shooting in a location that
didn't have
running water and barely had electricity
there were no bathrooms
and it was interior and it was in the
dead of summer super hot
and we were like bringing in fans but it
wasn't enough
it was a haunted attraction like a
closed down haunted attraction
that we were shooting in that was closed
for the summer
but they it was just a you know it was
ridiculous and there was a lot of
effects there was a lot of gore everyone
was getting covered in blood sticky
blood
and our days would always go longer and
longer and
you know we it was one of those shoots
where you start off with normal days and
then by like
day five or six you're starting at like
5 p.m you know
and it was really tough to make but that
ended up being
one of my most well-known successful
movies
i will say we were making it i had a
feeling about it that it would do well
that it would
do well and they would turn out well
actually i don't know if i'd managed to
do well i knew it would turn out well
because i just could see what i was
seeing on screen i could see the
you know in the monitor and on set i
could tell that it was
delivering it was the kind of movie i'd
like to see
you know that i would be happy with it
if i rented it that's like my gauge a
lot of times
you know most of the time is i want to
see a film i want to make a film that
i'd like to see and that i'd be
happy with as a jaded horror fan you
know
so yeah does one start out a jaded
horror fan or or it builds after
it builds it builds because because i i
see
i interact a lot with like fans and
stuff and there's like
fans of different generations who like
my some of my older movies and stuff and
there's like just starting out and
it's funny because like people it's fun
almost to see somebody get excited about
some 80s slasher that you've seen like
20 times or you've seen 10 times and
you're like yeah whatever what's the big
deal about that
but what is a big deal to them now
because they're just discovering it
but you do get yeah once you see more
and more stuff you do get jaded yeah
and then you've made movies too on top
of it
you really get you know it's it's hard
to maintain the
kind of enthusiasm and the um
you know the excitement about new
release horror you know
uh sometimes right you know we all i'm
coming here
whatever age always say well i'm not
gonna end up like that like sort of
dream crusher or whatever and then
i think enough things happen and you
don't mean to do it and i'm not saying
that's how you are i'm just saying but
we all have to like check ourselves
because it's like so easy
you do be dated about whatever it is i
saw a lot of that too
when i first moved here i saw it from
guys who were in their 40s
right when i was in my early 20s or
getting to my mid-20s i saw some guys in
their 40s who were super jaded and i
thought they had the best jobs in the
world
and i'm like what are you complaining
about what's your problem and you know
of course
there are levels to all these things
that people if you don't really know
them you don't know the whole story
but i i mean just having said that just
as a general statement i think it's
very very important to keep your
enthusiasm
about what you're doing and your
gratefulness for what you've
been able to accomplish because you know
it's very very hard to make any movie
any movie
any type of movie any budget movie
whatever it's very very difficult
and anyone who does that i mean that's
an accomplishment right there
and there's you know if you've been able
been lucky enough to make a few and then
some of those have actually gone out and
have fans and people that like your
stuff and they appreciate what you've
done
that that's you know you should be very
appreciative of that
i think i don't think you should ever
lose your appreciation for that or your
love of the game
and it's really hard to lose your it's
really easy to lose your love of the
game
because this is a very difficult game to
be in
it's probably easier to maintain your
love of cinema than it is
the business of cinema you know
but you can't have one without the other
so
yeah that's true i know sometimes i
think if you dip your toe back into what
you don't want
then you have a new appreciation for
kind of like
what you have a little bit because yeah
you can i think it's very easy to see
the glass half
empty we i think whereas humans are
engineered that way no matter what we're
doing what field we're in
but i see it sometimes from other
filmmakers that seem like they're not
my peers who have also some very cool
accomplishments but they always seem to
focus on the thing that they didn't get
the store that their movie didn't get
into the festival they didn't get into
the money they didn't make this that and
i'm thinking you know
you can choose to see it that way but
there's so many other good things that
have happened for your film that you
ought to be happy with
and sometimes that's something that
josephine and i talk about is
let's always be grateful and thrilled
for the stuff that goes right and stuff
that works and the people that
approach us about doing cool things with
the movie
because you should be appreciative of
that stuff and there's a lot of people
out there doing
it you know they're more people now than
when i started
making all kinds of movies so you do
have to kind of
you have to train yourself to see it
half full
i think because there's a lot of
negativity but you just don't want to
get
and let that be the me you're like your
go-to reaction
you know right and i like what you said
about there's difference between the
love of cinema and then the love for the
business but sometimes the love of
cinema
can re kind of re reignite it it does
it does i mean like we watch movies you
know regularly and all different types
of movies new movies old things that we
haven't seen sometimes watch something
that we just both love and
um like we both love paul schrader films
and like when we first met we first
started talking about paul schrader
and i thought it was this cool girl that
knows who paul schrader is and
she's in romania and she loves paul
schrader movies and and you know because
most people like when i was in film
school most people
were only interested in kevin smith and
tarantino they didn't care about bob
fosse schrader freaking
you know any of these guys so and i was
more interested in that type of stuff
so we'll just watch something that we
really love that we know it's good
and then you discover another layer of
it usually because these are great films
they hold up for
you know repeat viewings and you
discover another layer whether it's the
sound or the photography or a
performance or something so yeah you
need to renew your
your love for movies that way i think
for sure yeah and when all else goes
wrong
just yeah yeah yeah it's absolutely
absolutely remind you why you're doing
this why you're putting yourself through
this
and uh because well otherwise why am i
this torture that i'm torturing myself
here why you know well
you're it's something you're aspiring to
and it's also a world
that you want to contribute to and
that's what we're you know that's why
we're doing this because we want to
contribute to
to to to film to the you know not to
sound pretentious but the you know the
art of cinema or the history of film or
whatever you want to call it
so instead of must love dogs most love
right exactly that would be yeah
prerequisite
must be a fan of american gigolo and cat
people
do you feel like there are common traits
every horror protagonist has to have or
no it just varies from movie to movie
i think it very it seems to vary
you know i mean i i think that
i think the genre throughout history
has loved strong female characters i
really do
i mean i think that's something that you
can trace back
through many films you know you can go
back to the six you can go back to
rosemary's baby
you can go back to you know i'm sure
earlier examples
especially the 60s on and as you get
into the 80s and you get you know
the final girl from slasher films and
you get
the strong female lead from like
romero's dawn of the dead
you know sometimes they're just the
survivors but sometimes they're more
than a survivor they're an instigator
there
and nowadays you obviously it's i think
it's the whole game has changed
you know but i think that strong female
characters have been part of
the genre for for a long long time
i mean in this i'm not talking about
scream queens really i'm talking about
intelligent survivors who
you know have their wits like jamie lee
curtis and halloween this type of thing
or catherine ross and stepford wives
sure yeah yeah
i mean using this as more passive but
yeah yeah
yeah i think i mean i think that like
people use the term screen queen and i
think
when you know they kind of came up in
the 80s with slasher films and i think
there's a difference between like
the sort of the screen queen victim
sort of screaming type and the what like
jamie lee curtis was doing a lot of
times was she was genuinely
a tougher intelligent you know like she
the parts she played in halloween and
some of the other horror films she did
around that time
i think there's kind of there is a
difference there between those two
um sorry you know betty buckley and
carrie
who kind of like well i think carrie
herself i think spacek is like
i mean she's she's that's what's so cool
about that movie and that character and
that's why they keep people keep coming
back to it with remakes and stuff is
she's like the monster and she's kind of
the hero
i mean you really feel for her i mean
have you ever felt for a character so
much
in a horror movie or maybe almost any
movie i mean she is so
victimized and at the same time you
completely she's so relatable
like even if your situation you know
growing up wasn't that intense
you still relate to her it still has
pressures of high school and all that
stuff that stephen king tapped into
um i think that's an incredible
character you know that's and what's
cool is that she's
it creates weird feelings at the end
because she's you know killing all these
people and you sort of you don't know
how to feel about that because you're
like well
it's kind of awful but you're kind of
glad you're kind of happy for her it's
it's a mixed emotions but
yeah yeah that's a real traumatic movie
to see too
if you're under a certain age i think oh
yeah that my
my whole feelings about that movie have
actually like i've appreciated more and
more over the years
um i back then i was sort of under this
impression when i first saw those sort
of not a fan of de palma i thought his
movies were over directed
and too baroque and everything with a
split screen and all that
but since then like we've watched it a
few times and every time i watch i'm
like i'm not looking at any of that
stuff you're just looking at the
performances and how good they are
and you're just so involved in these
characters and
i think it's it's easily one of the best
stephen king
adaptations for sure maybe the best
you know one of the best out there
what's the best way to get people to
read your script
well you know those platforms have kind
of changed over time there used to be
different ways
to do that i mean
i
probably for me see i'm i've always
written with
with an eye toward directing so for me a
script is just a blueprint for a movie
that hasn't been made yet that's all
i've i've always seen it that way
even though i've done writing gigs you
know that for other you know for
different producers and the movie didn't
get produced but you know put everything
into that but
i've always written the scriptures with
you know with an eye toward getting it
produced and so
i would just i don't know like i think
you need to see nowadays it's so
different
it's so different i mean there's there's
still the
you know script shark and all these
different you know sites that people go
i don't trust those things
i don't trust those sites i i feel like
they just take your money and then who
knows what happens with it
you know i think i've been the i'm the
type of person who
i entered screenplay competitions early
on that's something i could say i think
it's good to enter screenplay
competitions i do
believe that i don't think there's
anything wrong with that just don't go
bankrupt doing it you know don't think
don't spend your last dime on it
but
i don't know i just i'm just the type of
person who
i never really entered a lot of things
like that i'm just i'm just telling you
i'm sure it doesn't make great interview
material it's a lot of stopping and
starting
i'm just i'm just being honest i mean
like i entered some screenplay
competitions and i placed in some of
them too
but those things didn't get produced and
then
the first screenwriting job i ever got
actually was while i was on kiss the
girls
i was walking around the set with horror
t-shirts on the exorcist
evil dead and the craft service guy said
you're a big horror fan and i said yeah
i'm a horror fan and i made some shorts
and he said
how about you rewrite a script from me
i'll pay you to rewrite a script
and this is the guy who's literally
picking up trash like he's got the you
know like the pointer you know
picking up trash and he's like i got a
horror script that needs a rewrite
and i remember he said to me we're
talking we're negotiating
and i he said um well i heard that
tarantino got
500 to rewrite from dusk till dawn
because that's what happened with that
that started as a
script by some effects artists uh who
wanted to make a movie and tarantino got
involved and that's how the whole thing
started
i don't know if that's how much he got
paid but anyway that's what this guy
said and i said he said five hundred
dollars he said how about if i give you
what tarantino got to do that i said
okay sure
of course i'll take that i'm thrilled
i'm 22 years old and i'm 21 years old
i'm working on a you know movie and i'm
gonna do a script rewrite on the side
so probably the reason i bring that up
is
you need to be around film people you
need to be around people who want to
make movies everybody's got a movie they
want to make
like remember another job i got this is
before i got anything produced another
screenwriting job i got was something
that i
it was a script i optioned that's what
it was it was some brothers it was like
two twin brothers
and they were friends of some effects
artists whose shop i was working in at
the time just you know i was doing
effects work
and they wanted to they were looking for
scripts that they could act in
just horror scripts whatever and so i
had this script i told my friend i wrote
a script and he said i'll show it to
these guys and
he showed it to him and they optioned it
from me and i remember they used to
finish each other's sentences on the
phone they were like it was like the
cohn brothers you know
so those are my first two like paid
script things
and it just came from being around film
people from being in the
i think people who just sit at home and
they are in front of the computer
they're not going to get anywhere with
that
you can submit to script shark you'll
spend money you won't make money you'll
spend money
it's not all about making money either
because somebody wants to make your
movie and you're gonna it's gonna get
off the ground that's
that's great if your first credit that's
a that's
you made it you know what i mean but um
in terms of like those are some of my
early experiences i don't know
you know i mean it's a cool story that
was in the 90s though right
so it wasn't the 90s there was i mean
there was a dial-up maybe
see all that stuff didn't exist and i
don't think that was just as well
because
these were fun i'm just telling you like
these were i had fun doing these things
like with with the guy with the craft
services
i mean i ended up going over with i
remember with him over to neo art and
logic which was neo
they were making movies with miramax
they're making horror movies with
miramax so i was sitting in their
offices
did that lead anywhere no but it was
just that was cool to be sitting there
you know and he was honest and he paid
me what he said he was going to pay me
and that movie didn't get made but so
what you know it was just a nice
gig and i did the best i could with it
and you know
and the thing with the brothers didn't
get made either but
the first thing that i wrote that got
produced was something i directed
it was a package deal i pitched um
[Music]
scream queen to the producer who i was
working as a pa i was working as a pa
on this movie and the producer was doing
smaller films
even smaller than the one we were making
and he said hey do you have some ideas
for some stuff
and and i pitched him a few and screen
queen was one and he said that sounds
good
let's do that so that was a writing
directing package
so once again i was on a set in the
desert in the mojave desert sitting in
the guy's
car talking at lunch and that was how
the deal was made
wow so they're all these things are all
bound up in
being out there and doing stuff they're
not about being at home
and emailing and texting and stuff but
like you said it was a 90s different
time and i know there's these sites out
there and stuff that people i don't like
i know people probably gotten stuff from
that too i'm not saying they don't but
that's just not my background you look
on mandy if you to
get a bit more updated or whatever if
you go on mandy and these sites people
are looking for scripts
people are looking for writers and i've
gotten jobs that way too
i've gotten jobs completely out of the
clear blue from a guy looking for a guy
to do rewrites on his horror script and
i've gotten jobs like that too
so it's of course that's yeah
i like that story that's one that wasn't
in the desert before it just sits at
home in front of my computer
that's just awesome the guy's just
picking this stuff up and that i mean
yeah he was literally picking up trash
and i had these t-shirts on and carrie
always was on that film too and he's
like oh man awesome sure
like he loved my extra sister because i
linda blair throwing up on the shirt
i had like different horror t-shirts all
i wore was black t-shirts back then
had evil dead reanimator and uh exorcist
so i just wear those every day and i
guess i became like the heart known as
the horror guy or something
and then and i was playing my short film
i was really obnoxious they had a tv in
the craft services trailer
and i would play my short film in there
any chance i got so people were
you know trying to get like some you
know you know an almond joy and they had
to like watch part of the movie while
they're in there
did they let you play it at the place
where they had the uh kerns next
nectars no no they had no interest in my
short film over there
i was just curious i got plenty of
plenty of kerns
you know and uh right whatever granola
bars but
but you weren't allowed to play your
short and then i don't think so they
didn't have anywhere to play it they
were playing it was just there's an
office you know i remember pulling up in
a drawer there was they asked me to file
some coverage and i pulled up in a
drawer and i saw the coverage for seven
pass not interested this will not do
well
pass and that's when you and that's good
to see things like that
too because you see that one person's
past is another person's huge success
you know if they take the
the chance on the project you never know
i mean no one knew seven would do as
well as it did i mean when that movie
came out it was so under
it was so under the radar you know so
it was interesting to see these things
like i saw we're seeing scary movie
before it was scream
and they probably passed on that one too
they had they were passing on a lot of
stuff
who was uh who's reading all this uh
well there were executives but there
they would
i mean they had i don't think they were
farming it out to readers they were just
using the interns as readers
you know like the big agencies have like
well they used to have before they
downsized they used to have readers so
that was their job just to read scripts
um but not really anymore
did they let you do that did you do that
they did i took scripts home with me and
read them yeah
yeah i would they would call the weekend
read i remember we'd meet like on a
thursday or
friday or whatever and they would they
give you scripts and then you'd come in
on like a monday
probably it's monday or tuesday and we
would all sit down
uh it wasn't a lot of people it's like
five people we'd sit on me and maybe two
other interns and we just
okay what'd you guys read what did you
think they wanted to know what we
thought
which was pretty cool you know um so i
was reading all different types of
movies too dramas
period pieces you know
sci-fi stuff they were they were reading
all they were
they had a lot of scripts coming in you
know were these younger people that were
having because did they want to know the
pulse of like the yeah
i don't know if they didn't i mean if
they did they didn't let on to that
um but there was me yeah all the interns
were the same age we're all in like our
early 20s
um you know so they but executives
weren't like
i mean they probably were maybe 10 years
older than us or something like that
you know um but i never i don't know i
mean i just you know we just did that
and
that was calling business as usual over
there so
but did you realize you were part of
this big machine or it felt that felt
like a big machine
i mean paramount in in in scot-free both
felt like big machines to me
they both felt like there's this machine
moving forward and
there isn't any particular person
driving it
it's just going and that's really how
big studio movies are more now more than
ever i would say
and development and a lot of this stuff
it's it's very hard they almost thrive
on a lack of like
one person being in charge or one person
taking the blame or you know
they specifically created that kind of
infrastructure so they don't nobody gets
really
you know nobody has to take the fall for
something that doesn't work
um but i just prefer
you know i think from an earl early on i
prefer this sort of lower budget film
sets
where the director is really directing
and the director doesn't show up nothing
happens
and you know it's just
more of a creative environment where
people can contribute more and
everybody gets to contribute more actors
everybody
you know um so
and i'm not saying these films were like
cakewalks because there was
you know there were ups and downs on all
these movies but that i saw happen
you know sometimes i was shocked you
know to see
people get overruled see directors get
overruled um
you know things like that you think
directors are gods
when you're growing up reading film
magazines you think that nobody tells a
direct and
that's the last word it's almost like
the old hollywood idea of that which i
don't know if even that was really true
but
at least that's the myth you know so to
see that
it was it was eye-opening to be on set
and see someone's like power you served
sort of yeah to see
like on spoiler there were scenes that
were literally there was an actor that
had makeup on
that he wanted to do and the director
wanted to do and one of the producers
found it offensive
she was like a devout christian and she
was offended by the makeup and she made
them reshoot that scene
um there are other times where one of
the producers who was out of town
doing probably a film market or
something because he was more like a
he was he had directed stuff in the past
but he was really more of a money guy
he came down toward the end and decided
he wanted to direct the movie
so there were parts of that movie where
the director was sort of
literally sidelined and that other guy
was calling action
and this type of stuff happens all the
time
but for me seeing that it was it was
eye-opening yeah for sure
to be on set and see someone's like
power you served sort of yeah to see
there were scenes that were literally
there was an actor that had makeup on
that he wanted to do and the director
wanted to do and one of the producers
found it offensive
she was like a devout christian and she
was offended by the makeup and she made
them reshoot that scene
there are other times where one of the
producers who was out of town
doing probably a film market or
something because he was more like a
he was he had directed stuff in the past
but he was really more of a money guy
he came down toward the end and decided
he wanted to direct the movie
so there were parts of that movie where
the director was sort of
literally sidelined and that other guy
was calling action
and this type of stuff happens all the
time but
for me seeing that it was it was
eye-opening yeah for sure
without mentioning any names did you
ever see people set up to fail
where you could tell like oh they gave
this person like a bad
opportunity and now someone else is
going to come and look like the hero
without naming i don't think i've seen
that that level of like you know
manipulation going on or overthinking
i've just seen directors
i mean it's happened to me but i've seen
it on a lot of films before you know i
started directing where
it was almost like they were they were
just being cut off at the knees
you know like there'd be we'd be
shooting like we did a film in romania
and
they just decided at one point they just
decided they stopped sending film stock
they like you know
had a delay i think i forget what
happened but it was some kind of a delay
in the delivery of film
a film negative and yet they weren't
going to necessarily give him extra days
to shoot you know the schedule wasn't
going to get longer you're just going to
you know
lose days because you didn't have film
delivered well
what do you expect you know what do you
expect for
those type of situation but so you know
i see people get put in situations where
it's like
you know what do you what do you think's
going to come out of this you know it's
not going to be good you're cutting your
own movie off basically but i've seen
that i've seen that time and time again
and i've seen that plenty of times on
things i've directed too
usually what it does what it is is if
anything it's producers who are lazy who
just figure well the director cares more
about this movie than i do
so i'm just not going to show up today
or
i'll show up for half the day or they
can just do whatever they can just you
know
manage it and guess what yeah we are
going to manage it because we do care
and we want the movie to come out well
so that's the kind of
that's i don't know if you call those
mind games i think it's sometimes it's
just more like laziness but there is a
little bit of a mind game going on there
because you
you're doing that knowing that the
person is gonna
you know take up the slack you know
do you let on that you know that or do
you try to carry on like everything's
great
and hopefully it becomes great i
probably
initially carried on more and didn't say
anything and then there were other times
where i flat i would tell them
what i thought you know i mean and
that's why
like this one producer that i did a lot
of movies for
i just stopped working with him after a
while because i just couldn't
i couldn't take it anymore i just
couldn't take but that and many other
things
ladies actually laziness incompetence i
can take more than like
meanness and name calling and personal
attacks and things like that
sure um but yeah you do get to a point
because you really are partners in this
i mean if you're making a move if you're
directing a movie
you know essentially on a lower budget
thing we usually would have a producer
and a director
let's just simplify things as far as i'm
concerned you're partners in that
it you know i mean when you're on set it
doesn't really matter who raised the
money or who's going to supervise
post or what when you're there making a
movie you should be equal partners in
that
and you know and by that
by that same standard you know if
they're not doing no not pulling their
weight or they're
making it hard on you you have the right
to call them out on that
so so if
if a let's say a new director is in a
similar situation it's their first time
experiencing that and they've heard
about this
that maybe they will be overthrown for
on their
on their set what's the best way to
handle it and still kind of preserve
their name
i mean if you've got people doing things
behind the scenes
that are trying to get somebody removed
which we've
actually just saying that made me think
of another situation not on something i
directed but something she and i both
worked on josephine i both worked on
that was definitely going on
um being set up to fail
i don't know i think you just have to
carry on until you know
and especially if it's your first movie
or second movie or whatever you're just
trying to
get some films completed and have a
track record as a
director i think you need to try to keep
it
even keel as much as you possibly can
you know because i do know a lot of
people by the same token i know a lot of
people have made one movie and that's it
because of you know whatever
temperament issues or blowouts or things
that didn't go well and it just turned
into such a
fireball that that was it for them
there's a lot of people like that too
you know and they wanted to make more
films but they're not gonna
because it just blew up so much so i
think you have to try to keep it
keep a lid on it as much as you possibly
can
i don't know i think everyone everyone
has their own personal
gauge of that well some people are great
at being politicians and they like you
know
the game someone's playing and they can
still just be smooth back and make sure
they
and other people i think wear their
heart on their sleeve or they're just
more like
no i'm gonna call bs when i see it i'm
just gonna like i
i was suffering yeah i was definitely
not doing that i mean you know you'd
have to feel like you know you
for example i did a film this was a
problem with the dp
not with the producer with the dp
sometimes dps can
try to take over movies and be very
bullying because they know they have the
power especially if they have their own
camera package and everything that can
happen sometimes
and i did one movie where you know the
dp was really pulling
you know he was he was just making it
clear that he was you know going to
make determine a lot of things about
when we're going to stop start and stop
and how much they're going to do and
this and that and
i really kept my mouth shut through the
entire process because
i had a friend who had money in that
film you know a personal friend
i had more or less some money in the
movie at that point
and i really cared a lot about that
movie and i wanted to preserve it and
complete it
so a lot of times you will just
i was not wearing my heart on my sleeve
for my first few years
of directing i think later on yeah i'll
start to
make more you know comment more on
things that aren't working
right or whatever but yeah it's
interesting how managing egos is such
like an important skill and adult life
that
no school really prepares you for well
you know well you know the best way to
put it is like like joseph and i both
say this like on the movies we're doing
now we're in charge but
like you can say you're in charge but at
the end of the day you're really trying
to
to get the best out of everyone and work
with everyone and do what's best for the
movie
so really the movie's in charge you know
and the movies in charge i mean and
that's the same with the one i just
mentioned in the desert i mean what's
really important the movie
that's the most important thing so is it
about
telling somebody to their face what you
think about them either privately or
publicly or is it about completing the
movie and then moving on to the next
project
because you can always do another movie
and then you can work with somebody else
next time
that's usually how you handle those type
of situations
um and we've both gotten try to become
more and more diplomatic over time
um we try to learn from our experiences
and you know um
just you know kind of keep the diplomacy
as much as you possibly can until it
just absolutely is obviously not working
but even that's usually more like a slow
fade than a
than a big explosion with most people
you know so i like that the movie's in
charge
it is it's the most important thing and
it looks nice people do crazy things
because of that
you know sometimes people put their
lives in danger and other people's lives
in danger because of that directors get
huge egos the move
i mean i know i'm i see it from all
different angles and especially
since we've been executive producing
things lately we are on the other side
of the table
so we see it even more from that
perspective which is interesting
uh but yeah the movie ultimately that
does need to be the the main thing
everyone's
working toward and if some other people
don't care about it and they're gonna
quit or they're gonna
you know do whatever well you know what
you still need to complete it and
and to the best of your ability you
still need to finish it and
for for your own sake and for the film's
sake
you know so relax
the movie's in charge yeah yeah it is i
mean it really is you know
and it's going to do what it's going to
do later on too you know it's gonna
every film's gonna you know however much
how hard you work on it
it's all gonna have they're all gonna
have their own path and their own
success
or lack of success or exposure or fandom
or lack of
interest or whatever you just never know
you really never know anybody who thinks
that
who says they know is is lying
you know yeah and i know it's a very
sort of dark place for
for anybody who completes something i'm
sure it's the same for a book as well
that like
okay it's done and now like
the reactions are going to be what it's
going to be and then be a very dark
place oh yeah i mean we're
we're at that place right now not a dark
place thankfully but we're in that place
right now where we're getting our first
reviews
for our movie high death and actually
all of them have been good
they've all been pretty good i'm not
going to say they're all four star
ratings
but we haven't gotten any bad reviews
yet on the movie and it's funny though
because
the first review i ever got or one of
the first i ever got was in a print
magazine in fangoria and it was a very
bad review
and it broke my heart and at one level i
was thrilled to be in the magazine
on another level i was upset because
they hated the movie
and i think over time i've gotten more
and more
like i get less and less bothered by
reviews
i think the more stuff you make the more
movies you have out there
and you know the more frankly other
things you do with your time
you will care less about that i i think
you know every movie is going to have
its fans and its detractors
and you know you will not find one movie
that everybody loves
you know and you find plenty of movies
especially in the horror genre that
people love or hate so
you get less bothered by that over time
but it is always a little bit of a
suspense you you're putting when your
first reviews start rolling in and
you're like oh
see what people think you know
if negative reviews don't bother you
what does bother you
just having a difficulty getting another
film off the ground
that that bothers me a whole lot more
seeing a land the landscape shrink
in terms of distribution opportunities
in terms of
you know places that are interested in
playing or screening independent movies
you know i mean what bothers me like
netflix bothers me
you know they bother me because they put
the independent
they put video stores out of business
they put a lot of independents out of
business
and they're just doing their own stuff
and i think they had that plan all along
i'm not a fan i'm never going to
subscribe to them and i'm never going to
be a fan of them
that bothers me that bothers me a lot
more than a bad review because
the movie like my movie camp blood which
was the first movie of mine to be
released
like commercially released third movie i
directed but first to be released
fangoria hated it gave it a terrible
review but
it was very very popular not only here
but also in england to the point where
we did a sequel the next year that's how
popular it was
um we did the third one a few years
later
that franchise is still going there's
people who contact me all the time about
those movies and how much they enjoyed
them and love them and want me to sign
them and this and that and the other and
they've become part of like the
especially the independent horror
landscape
well what that goes to show you is don't
take those reviews that seriously
because you never know one critic
doesn't like it maybe somebody else does
and if people are interested in the
movie and they like it and
it strikes a chord with the fans
that matters way more to me than any
reviewer
um because i'm a fan and i want
my movies to deliver for the fans too
you know
i want to you know i want to make a
movie like the one i'd like to see
so yeah reviews don't bother me i mean
and i
i think you can get very like what was
what did i
see one person there was a quote this
other director said i only
the only reviews i care about are the
good ones you know
because it's true you know you can you
can do that too it's almost like you
maybe you shouldn't look at any of them
then
you know but you know we're still going
to look at our
our press because we're interested you
know it's all you know whenever you have
a new movie out
but like the last film we did not this
one that just came out but the last one
we did high eight
we did it completely on a wing and a
prayer and we didn't care what anybody
thought of it
i couldn't care less because the thing
was so low budget
and independent that nobody i mean i
told everybody to make the movies i said
don't worry about it
just make something you want to make and
don't worry about anyone likes or
doesn't like
and you know what people love that movie
it was embraced the way you you can't
you couldn't buy the publicity we were
getting like
page length articles and magazines i
could never get them to do anything
before and they were doing on their own
volition because they
loved the movie and the festivals that
took it
and the fans and everything that's why
we made a sequel because
this film was so embraced but we did it
without caring
you have to do that sometimes you have
to not care what people think or what
you think people are going to like or
not like or what your last
reviews for your last movie where you
you really can't care about that
if you do then you're just going to stop
you're just going to get frozen and just
stop
and that goes back to the facebook group
where you guys all said you wanted
fun stuff yeah exactly like one of the
filmmakers i remember
direct quote from him was remember when
this used to be fun
quote and he was he was basically a guy
my age
because some of the filmmakers are older
than me some some of the filmmakers
involved with hiat i grew up watching
their movies
oh wow like like i was renting their
stuff from the video store when i was in
my teens or late teens
um they're you know like they're my
heroes and
um but with the guy who said that yeah
he he was he really struck a chord
remember when this used to be fun
because we all remember when it used to
be fun when we were out shooting with
our friends
in the backyard with the height camera
or whatever camera we had
and we weren't worried about netflix or
amazon
or blockbuster or what store used to
have our movie but they closed or
who's going to take our film who's not
going to take our film what demographics
say
or what magazine we weren't thinking
about any of that stuff back then we're
just we're just making
films so you need to go back to that we
went back to that and then i think it
and everyone got it the fans they like
this is this is like
feels like one of these old movies and
you know it's it's got that free spirit
that creative spirit
so you know it just goes to show you
that you never know
you just kind of follow we really
followed our instincts with that one
you know so yeah it could be risky or
it could go nowhere but we didn't care
because we're like well we're not
risking enough to worry about that you
know
you know why not pitch
netflix and get them to do an upcoming
project
i doubt i would ever get in the room
with them i mean i'm just being honest i
just i don't know how it i don't know
how i would get in the room with them
um you know i
it's weird in this business too and this
is the honest truth
is you know i'm sure i mean i'm not
saying it was easy for the duffer
brothers with stranger things but it did
probably help that they hadn't done a
whole lot
um when they pitched that what happens
in this business
is it's sort of a double-edged sword is
you know if you start to do things and
you have
a track record and you made x number of
movies well
okay that's great because it shows you
can do this and you can do it you've
done it more than once and obviously
you've got some kind of
you know track record skills and so on
but for some people depending on the
type of movies you make in
my case it's horror movies that's a
stigma
it stigmatizes you and then most people
think that's all that they can do
that's all that guy knows how to do um i
mean
let's just i just throw a name out there
wes craven on a obviously
way bigger level you know he struggled
with that his entire career
that's why he made the movie with meryl
streep because he just wanted to he was
tired of making hard
he wanted to make other things most
horror directors want to make other
types of movies
they just don't get to george romero had
plenty of things he wanted to do wes
craven things
they all do john carpenter all of them
but they're generally not going to get
it and i'm talking about major people
here
they're not going to get it because
their track record says
he makes this type of film so my track
record says i make these type of films
and i don't think that
netflix would care about that i think
they'd see that as a negative maybe if
i'd only made one short they might be
interested in having a meeting with me
you know a short that was very hot let's
just say played at you know some major
fest
but and that doesn't mean and that's not
because i don't have any ideas for
things or i don't have ideas that could
be expanded to
tv series but yeah
so having you know been here in the 90s
and then um you know entering a new
era where there's there's going to be
younger people in charge
do you find they have a harder time
telling you no than maybe
gen xers or people in in
in another decade where it seemed like
it was okay to be a little more blunt
and now we're very sensitive and we're
dancing on everybody's feelings
and nobody wants to tell anybody no but
then they're not telling you the truth
because
i'm seeing a lot of that and sometimes
maybe it's just better people just tell
you no
well yeah i think it yeah there is a
there is a
it's it's because of you know so much
online communication you know there's
the classic you know no response you
know sort of the ghosting
or whatever that people do where they
just if they they don't want to
they want to move away from the
situation or say no or whatever they
just won't do anything
i guess like no response is okay
whatever that is you know
i don't know i mean we're
we're pretty straightforward with people
like we're very straightforward in
auditions
we're very straightforward in uh
meetings about like when we're
interviewing uh
crew you know that doesn't mean that
things aren't still gonna come up later
sometimes it doesn't matter how much you
talk to you're blue in the face and
impress something upon someone
they'll always there they aren't
listening to you or they've got an
agenda or they just
decide that they've you know they've got
another idea later on that can all
happen you have to be prepared for that
we just we just try to be as
straightforward as possible what other
people do
we can't really say but if we get a bad
vibe off of somebody
or our non-committal vibe or whatever we
just move on
you know sure i mean i just there's a
lot of moving on you do in this in this
business
too much you know and and sometimes it
happens way quicker than you think it
will
but that's just that's something else
you need to get used to if you're gonna
have a career
i think on any level is is just used to
change
and new faces and
you know and kind of self-starting
you know and coming up with things like
almost like every film is your first
film you know
i'm sure you've heard that before people
say you know i feel like every time
i've felt that way many times that i'm
trying to pitch something to some people
and i'm going
why do i even have to do this i've got
over 20 features
because because that's just how this
business is people
you know they always want you always got
to prove yourself to somebody in some
way
some more than others but you know
but knowing that doesn't make it less
stressful
knowing that you have to like self-start
again and then you just go okay one back
here it's annoying i mean i'll be honest
with you it's annoying and
of course because you you know there's
other people that don't have to do that
so there are i mean on a higher tier
there are people who don't have to do
that but there's an alarming number of
accomplished people who do
you know so that makes it a little bit
easier to take i guess when you know
that
you know some of your heroes still have
to you know put on a dog and pony show
for you know
investors or whatever um
i don't know i mean we we've tried to
we've tried to take things try to be as
calm as we can
over time that's one thing that
josephine and i both tried to sort of
learn
with some of these experiences is you
can get very heated over these little
situations sometimes with film
that's something i'd probably tell
anybody really is a lot of times
it's not as big a deal as you think it
is if it's an editing
issue if it's a sound issue if it's a
certain shot
you don't believe me it's not as big a
deal as you think it is
um you know sometimes you can get very
fixated on these type of things and you
can get very stressed about this stuff
it's not about personality so this is
technical things too
you just try to be as calm as you can
in those type of situations you know
which part of the screenwriting process
is most difficult for you
i would say the first draft is the most
difficult
looking at the blank page you know
actually the the treatment i always
write a treatment before
i write a script and i know that sounds
really
elementary but there are people i know
who don't really do that they just want
to start writing and see what happens
i'm like what's gamma's you're gonna
have an unfinished script
you know you're gonna get into the third
of the way through and realize you don't
have an ending a middle or an ending and
you wasted your time
i mean i've highly highly highly
recommend
writing the whole thing out as a
treatment and make sure it works and
make sure it's a feature-length piece
too
i mean for me treatments are always
one page of treatment kind of equals
like 10 pages of script
that's how my treatments have always
worked out so if i have a
you know if my treatment is at least
seven or eight pages or nine pages or
something you know you
you probably don't have a whole movie
there but writing the first draft's
always the hardest and just
for me the reason it is is because i
want to get everything right the first
time
i don't want to do another draft i want
to get every dot
you know dot the eyes and cross the t's
and have the perfect adjectives picked
out and the perfect
cadence and you know this kind of stuff
so
i will kind of agonize over that and
sometimes you need to almost just be
like you know what
like if you come to a scene that isn't
working that well just
almost like drop in a i say hate to say
it but like a space like a
space saver or something you know kind
of like a little uh block and then go to
the next scene
if you can because then you can come
back to that later you know and and
be more inspired maybe you'll be more
inspired the next day but just keep
moving through it you know and i always
write a certain number of pages per day
no matter what
that's another discipline thing i kind
of picked up like after moving here
was because i had to sometimes write
scripts very quickly
i had to like deliver scripts within a
few weeks or a month or whatever it was
so i i could i got a discipline from
that
um but but that first draft is always
the hardest yeah so much easier to
rewrite than to write
you know are you able to write at home
or do you have to go somewhere
i i couldn't i have to write at home
even if there's construction going on
around
and there's like whatever noise i've
written so many scripts
under like bad noisy circumstances
unfortunately because i
have to be at home and i have to be in
my environment like i'm not one of those
people who can go in a coffee shop and
write
i don't know how people do that with all
the noise and
kind of commotion and frankly other
people with laptops and stuff all around
you who are probably also writing
scripts
it's just kind of you know that those
type of environments don't work for me
so i've always written like i couldn't
even i tried to write a script one time
at a friend's house i was house sitting
and i couldn't do it
i left i called another friend up and i
said can you house it for this guy
because i can't stand it i have to go
home and be in my place and write this
my script i can't write it here in his
place so
yeah so i have all everything i've ever
written has been
at home yeah
so was that something you always did was
do the space saver
yeah i've done that more lately it kind
of depends on the script
like sometimes if it's a script
especially if it's a script you're
writing for someone else
like i was writing i got this job to
write a script for about like a mummy
movie for this guy one time
and it was like a mummy on a it was
called we were calling it mummy on
campus for a while but that
anyway that wasn't the end of the title
we ended up with but it was a mummy film
on a
college campus and there were some
scenes where i was like yeah i know
exactly what i want to do with that
you know i'm going through the treatment
and there'd be like a part where i'd be
like you know what i just don't feel
like writing that right now you know
like some attack some action scene or
some kind of complicated sequence it was
my fault because i came up with it
anyway
but i would just skip over to the next
scene and then i'd come back to that one
so you know everybody has their own way
of
uh their own writing technique i guess
and so i'll do that sometimes it depends
um and so then could you work that out
later like you know what you're waking
up and you're like i just figured out
the
best way to like have the money money be
in the campus square or
a placeholder yeah you put a placeholder
there or it might or it might be for me
sometimes i don't have a hard time
writing action
i'm not a big fan of writing dialogue
that's something i don't like and the
directors who i'm a big fan of are not
dialogue oriented directors
uh like walter hill is one of my
favorites and you know he's
always got short real short lines
characters don't
yak a lot in his movies so sometimes
it'll come to a certain scene like it
could be a big dialogue scene or
something and i'll be like you know what
depends on where you're at in the day
but i'll be like i think i'll come back
to that tomorrow
or you'll just write some dialogue and
then you'll come back to and rewrite
polish it
you know so i mean to me a first draft
is always like there's a bunch of
polishing that goes on in that draft
it's not just a first draft like oh here
it is done and i just fell right off the
table and here it is you know it's
there's always a certain amount of
polishing that that you do
you know and it kind of depends on
whether you're writing it for yourself
or if you're writing for someone else
because sometimes when you're writing
for
a producer or some company you know
that they're going to make a lot of
changes to it anyway and you've been
having meetings and you've seen that
stuff happening
so that sort of plays into your
decisions sometimes too
to you know how you approach it
you know the guy that saw you in the
horror shirts that was picking up
the trash at the uh on on by the craft
services or whatever
was that your that was your first
rewrite or sort of yeah
it was my first rewrite because he had
the script i still remember what was
called was called queen of angels
and it was it was a i think it was a
ghost movie
in a hospital like in a haunted hospital
and he even knew where he wanted to film
it
there's a hospital called linda vista
hospital that's like been a location for
many years for
all kinds of movies and i think we might
have filmed there from that
show i can't remember but anyway that's
what it was and he
and you know i just i don't remember
though the details of what i did on it
like i think i don't remember what he
wanted me to do with it you know what i
mean because it wasn't like it was
unfinished i mean it was a completed
script i think he just wanted me to
maybe like make it scarier i've had
people tell me that before make it
scarier
okay different people think different
things are scary
so that's true so you kind of like
you go through the initial read with it
yeah yeah i would i would read it i
think on that one i read it and then i
maybe there were certain scenes he
wanted me to like pump up a bit like the
horror scenes maybe he wasn't that
comfortable with the horror scenes
um geez you know i
i don't remember now but it was
you know but he did have a finished
script which
the i've had other jobs where people
call me up
i had one gig where a guy called me up
to write to
finish his script and not only finish it
but right around scenes he had already
shot
for the movie so he had like a script
some of those scenes are in the script
already been filmed like years ago
and i was supposed to write the rest of
it like kind of like the i guess for
better lack of a better term he
had the beginning and i had to write the
middle in the ending so i did it
but that was weird because not only did
i have to match his
first act let's say i also had the match
clips that were shot like in you know
with these different actresses
that were already existing footage which
you know for me i was thinking myself or
how are you going to match that footage
in terms of the shooting then you start
thinking about
the technical end of it in the
production and but i was like
whatever so i wrote that i was just
wondering how valuable that
one experience where you meet this guy
in the most unlikely
situation that's your first job in a
sense which is so cool
and maybe because it was a relaxed thing
like that it actually
helped you more than if it was like well
yeah come on in and then you feel this
immense pressure oh yeah no it was done
very casually
literally he was he was literally
picking up the trash while he was asking
me to do it
and i remember that and you know
i mean i just thought that was very
flattering and i couldn't believe it
you know i thought i was the luckiest
luckiest guy in the world
you know i get to do that and it was i
was nervous when we went over to neo
went over to their offices because i was
like wow i'm in the offices of these
you know this established film company
because he knew those
those guys he knew the producers over
there and probably he was trying to push
the
queen of angels on them um
but yeah it was it was cool that it was
done so casually and
and the subsequent some of the
subsequent jobs i did too were also
casual and
they were very kind of off the cuff like
you know just
like this guy at this effects shop
saying hey i've got some guys looking
for a script and do you have anything
and i'm like yeah i've got this
horror action script you know that i
wrote on spec that i had
i planned on making in virginia beach
which did not happen
but i had it and they optioned it from
me
you know and that was once again done in
a very casual laid back i think i met
with them in like a starbucks or
something and
you know drew up a short form agreement
so i was just wondering how like some
people might pass over certain
opportunities because they're not
it's not like this huge like hollywood
you what you envision
but how that actually groomed you to
then i mean
you took those opportunities you saw
them maybe as like okay i'll do it and
then
yeah really it's all about you know a
lot of this this business is built on
give and take
and you know sort of you know people
doing favors for each other and helping
each other out at different points in
time
and i had done work talking about the
option job i had done work for that
effect shop
i i knew them from that background they
helped me out with
effects people i needed for my stuff
that i was directing
i ended up they helped me out with that
with the option thing then later on they
had a script that they
i did like a little rewrite on so it's
always this kind of you know we're
we're just hanging out i mean this is
this did not feel like business
you know it was but it wasn't you know
it felt more
and i would and i wasn't remotely
thinking about all this stuff is
is too i'm too good for this stuff i
never thought that i thought it was cool
and
fun and you know i was having fun
frankly
so you know and i was learning a lot too
sometimes without even realizing it
every every job you get
you learn from every script you write
every movie you produce or direct or
whether you instigate it and bring it up
from the ground up or you get brought in
on it i mean you learn on every single
one
you know maybe that was it what you just
said like
you didn't think you were too good for
and maybe just seeing that opportunity
i seems like yeah everybody does that
there's move there's definitely movies
i've directed like and so you know i'll
tell you something
there were people when i first started
directing very low budget micro budget
movies who made fun and they were
friends of mine who were my age who were
starting
trying to get in as well and they were
they would make fun of me they would
make fun of my
everything about what i was doing they
make fun of the films i was directing
they make fun of the producer on those
they make fun of everything
guess what they're not directing they
didn't direct anything and they never
did
they just made fun of me and tried to
denigrate what i was doing
and i some of those people i just cut
them loose to be honest with you that
was one of my first like things i kind
of learned out here was like
not only how to build relationships but
also how to get rid of negative
dead weight sometimes too and
you know there's a lot of people that
will scoff at things or say i would
never do that it's like yeah don't worry
you won't
you know um you know like i had a guy
used to say i would never do a movie for
so-and-so and say yeah you won't because
he's not going to ask you to
you know i mean it's easy to say what
you won't do
but i don't know yeah i'm not big on
turning things down
you know there's a few movies i've
directed that i'm not very happy with or
whatever but
you know overall for me it's hard to
take those pieces out of the puzzle
because everything leads
to you know each project sort of leads
to the next one
it's it would be very very hard for me
to just
take them all apart and you know
separate all my work to separate all my
credits or all my
off my resume because there's a line
that kind of goes through all of it
do you know what i'm saying usually one
thing leads to another usually one job
does lead to another
and sometimes you have to self-start and
and create your own job
create your own opportunity that too
but yeah sitting around saying i'm too
good for that i'm not going to do that
and
that's not going to get you anywhere
right yeah it's just interesting how all
that kind of just then led
you know and and some people would have
said oh this guy yeah i'm not going to
you know oh yeah
i had friends from film school who moved
out here who would make fun of
uh you know literally make fun of things
that people i was working with and make
fun of stuff and i was kind of like you
know what it's it's okay
just go do whatever you're doing and you
know
um it's all right you know you don't
have to do it you know
you don't have to be on this project you
know um
it's i don't know i mean people have
snobbism
about them you know and
i haven't seen that getting anybody
anywhere though and all the people
the directors i know who are like
working for years and making things and
however they're making them
whatever they're they're all
self-starters and they're not snobs and
they're not
they're all hard workers and they all
love what they do
and they've all taken a lot of abuse or
grief or
had a lot of difficulties over the years
but they still do it
so you know i think you kind of make a
decision early on in this business is
you're going to continue with it or not
because you if you don't want to do this
you know if you don't want to take these
lumps then just get out of it
because there's a lot easier things you
could be doing a lot more profitable
you know a lot easier things you could
be doing with your your life
you know but i don't feel like i chose
it i feel like it shows me
you know i i do i mean
so and and some people are like i had no
idea if there was anything else i wanted
to do
this was interesting but yeah you know
i don't yeah i can't think of anything
else i'd rather be doing
i mean i i love writing you know i i
sometimes that's my
you know but that's all bound up in the
film too so you know i do
journalism things here and there but you
know what i mean it's it's still all
connected
so okay so i have a quote here sykes
film death factory became its
distributor's all-time top grossing
title
and was also later sequelized how much
money is that six figures
seven figures i will i will never know
the answer to that question
because i'm not privy to that type of
thing
when we made death factory it was
like a work for hire situation and for
this
distributor who had distributed movies
that i directed
prior to that and done well with and he
started his own company
called brain damage films and death
factor was one of their first
movies that they paid for like they
basically this is what distributors were
doing back then a lot of
especially smaller companies they were
doing well enough that they would
produce their own product they would
produce their own films
that they could own outright and then
they would you know use their
distribution
you know arm to get them into the stores
and stuff
so that's what death factory was and i
felt like it was going to be a good
movie when we made it but then it turned
out to
not only turn out pretty well but it
also was very successful i got into
blockbuster it was my first movie in
blockbuster it was
you know that was really cool to to see
it and it got some good reviews too as
well received
you know in the horror community and
that was pretty much the end of that i
mean i i keep hearing from people about
it and it was released all over the
world too i mean i've got
i mean death factories released in uk
germany
poland you know russia
france everywhere i mean pretty much
every
country you can think of you know and
they did do a sequel but i was not
involved in the sequel
i don't know how much you want to hear
about that but i can tell you things if
you want to hear them
uh it was actually i did i knew it was
the best-selling title because that was
in a magazine that quote was in a
magazine
i saw an interview with the distributor
and he said this death factor is our
best-selling title
and then a few years after that i was at
a film market
and in santa monica and i was they had
all these rooms they take over and
and i went up to the room i was kind of
doing my rounds at the time
and i went in the room brain damages
room and i'm talking to
the president and i'm looking around the
room
and i and i just made a movie called
plaguers which is a pretty big movie
bigger than anything they've ever done
and they probably weren't thrilled with
me because i hadn't given it to them to
distribute
but i'm looking around the room and i
see a poster for death factory sequel
death factory bloodletting it was called
and i was like
hey i see you made a sequel to death
factory you know
great that's that's good to know and
basically what happened with that was
there was a guy over there
at the company who was a very power
hungry younger guy
who they're going to make that sequel
but he didn't want anybody who was
involved with the first one
involved with that why would you want
them right they're just the people that
made the movie that made you all the
money
so they made the movie there they're in
arizona they made the movie there
with people that were local they didn't
bring anybody
from la on to that and they never asked
me even if i wanted to even contribute
like to the
the screenplay and i had to fight
to even get my credit on there as a
story you know characters based on
characters created by which is a
standard credit you see on any
sequel or you know any indiana jones
movie or whatever
you know that's been franchised out i
had to fight for that credit and
they kind of gave it to me kind of they
gave me like a
reduced version of that if you can
imagine that
so and that and that one didn't do as
well as the first one
it came out but it was like a non it was
almost like a non
event um and you know
so that's the kind of thing that can
happen in this business sometimes when
you make a successful movie
you most people would automatically
assume that you would be brought on to
the sequel or they would want you on the
sequel
or something like that but in that case
it was because of the power dynamics
that were going on behind the scenes
that me neither me nor the producer of
the original death factory were
were involved and if you hadn't have
gone to that
film market and been up there making
your rounds you may have never
discovered that right oh i would have
discovered it was some somebody would
have told me
some fan or somebody would have told me
or i would have maybe seen the movie
for sale somewhere or something like
that but it was weird when it came out
because that sequel they didn't release
it themselves
so that was weird because they're a
distributor they gave it to somebody
else and then it
it just didn't go anywhere which i was
like well you know what it's
fine with me i mean you know i wasn't
really
in the cheering section for that project
all it did was just prove that i made
another movie that that did well enough
that was secret that's
to sequalize cam blood was one death
factory is another one and you know now
we've got sequel to hiate also
so you know it gives you some kind of um
makes you feel like you you have your
your align on something
uh creatively speaking to be able to
come up with some concepts that
are popular enough
to you know to have people want to
sequalize them and
and you know because that doesn't happen
with every movie
obviously is that something going
forward when you
have things put in contracts that if
they decide to make the sequel then that
you have to somehow either be credited
involved because was that something you
didn't think was ever going to happen
i i well you know it's funny when
when we made death factory i'd already
done a sequel to camp blood
so obviously i was already in that you
know i'd already had things sequalized
but you know it's one of those things
where the contracts back then were such
like short
form things and there was always that
looming threat of if you don't want to
do this someone else can do it
you know and believe it they didn't mind
telling you that
you know so when i made the movie
but but i didn't think it would there
would be a sequel to death factory but
then again i didn't think there'd be a
sequel to camp blood either
so i didn't have any any kind of a
clause now future things that we've done
since then especially things that we do
through nightfall
we do have more clauses in those type of
agreements and
with whether it's you know initial
production agreements or it's
with distributors you know with things
like that in terms of we
we really go over these contracts and
really make sure we can
we look at every single right that we're
signing off on because
all of these rights matter and more now
than ever i would say
and if there's a right that they don't
want well we'll retain it and if there's
a right that we real
we really think we need to keep then
we'll argue for it and keep it
you know um that's something frankly
that josephine is more
adept at than me you know
we both look at the contracts but she's
she's in favor of protecting me actually
and
and trying to get us the best deals
and the best agreements and protect
ourselves too for like future you know
sequels or or renewals you know you have
sometimes with you know re-licensing
this type of stuff so we're
you know it's always a learning process
everybody's always learning and
most filmmakers they make bad deals and
things like that in their first films
because they just want to get the movie
released and
you know right i guess because there's
that hunger and then it is true
that there's people that will take your
place if you don't oh yeah yeah and i've
had i've had that happen to me i mean
i've had movies that i
i had one film for this same producer
where i i just
basically i've stepped off of it because
i said you know i
it collapsed i won't get into the
details but it collapsed after i'd done
a ton of work on it and i said i said to
him you know what
i can't rebuild this whole movie again
like in terms of rescheduling re
reproducing almost the whole movie and
then he said okay fine and then he went
and just got somebody else to direct it
and
you know it wasn't anything great it
wasn't anything special it's not like
something i wish i'd done that because
that movie turned out to be a huge hit
and
no not hardly but that type of thing can
happen to you anytime
even on these tiny films people think
that stuff happens on big studio movies
people look well yeah it does i mean
it's people lurking around
it happens on low budget films all the
time you know in fact it might even
happen more because they're more people
that
are angling to get up the ladder quicker
whereas on studio film like a paramount
film the grip is probably okay with
being a grip
you know the the the you know the guy
who's doing craft services he's probably
cool with that he's doing pretty well
with that and he's probably all right
with it he doesn't want to direct the
movie you know or any movie
whereas i feel like on these smaller
films that's the downside to the low
budget is everybody's kind of like
angling to bump up the ladder
so you know i've had you know effects
people want to direct and you know dp
wants to direct there's always
you know i'm not saying that's on every
set but it does happen
so you know and when it happens to you
it actually really happens to you then
you really become
aware of it you know yeah that's the
interesting part about the entertainment
industry that
that's that angling i like that yeah
they are they're angling and i mean
we've been had on
i mean you know it happens on everything
yeah in a lot of scenarios and so i
think it's just being aware of that
yeah and then sort of like okay i'm
feeling that there's an angling but i'm
not sure what it is
and then just being ready to be
protective yeah but that was one of
those situations you mentioned earlier
did i speak up did i
say what i thought oh yeah i did because
that was toward the end of my
working relationship with that guy and i
did tell him in no uncertain terms i'm
not
rescheduling this entire film and
bringing all these people and
everything on you know re because they
have they have schedules too
believe it or not everybody has
schedules and i was not going to redo
the whole film
just just because one person didn't show
up and then the whole thing started
falling like a house of cards sometimes
these movies are very fragile
things and they're fragile for us i mean
it's always scary
you know shooting especially on lower
budget things it's always scary to
there's always a little terror involved
because you want everything needs to
come together
right then and there for it to really
work so there's always
a lot of stress i don't care how many
movies you made you know
the day before the night before you
don't get a lot of sleep
yeah that's true and then you have to be
up so early and then yeah
you're like a mess for that one day and
then i mean we were we were like
like the last thing like on high death
we shot at bronson caves and
you know that's all outdoors obviously a
whole day we're going to be outdoors and
if
you have weather issues that's it you're
not going to shoot and we had everything
prepped so
the night before literally at like two
in the morning at three more we started
hearing rain
there was like unforecast rain coming
down it was like three a.m four am like
this day is screwed
but luckily by the time we actually got
out there which was pretty early in the
morning still probably six or seven a.m
it had stopped raining and it is
starting to dry off a little bit
but you know those type of things can
drive you nuts i mean when you shoot
outdoors weather is like
sometimes you can save a lot of money by
shooting outdoors but
the downside is if you have inclement
weather or other noise issues or things
it can really
bite you you know
are the distribution deals better now
than when you first started out
no no i don't think so i mean
because distribution deals when i first
started
were patterned built largely on foreign
sales
for one thing another thing they were
patterned or built on was
you know the infrastructure the sale the
retail and rental
infrastructure we have here so you know
you could take a given movie
like say camp blood and that movie
sold so well internationally forget
about you didn't even come out in the
u.s
it sold so well internationally that the
foreign sales company was handling it
asked us not just asked us commissioned
us paid for
a sequel right then and there because
they had done so well with just to
selling it to
what they uk had paid for example um who
let alone other countries that bought it
so you know and then the movie you know
had a
well second and third life um
not just in overseas but here of course
you know and for rent
and you know dvds sales and all this
kind of stuff
those markets they're not really there
anymore for
lower budget movies and all kinds of
things
they're you know i mean foreign sales
have been devastated by piracy
to a large degree it's very hard to you
know sell to spain for example because
they pirate everything over there before
it's come out
so you can forget about that um
there's just you know the countries that
do buy are pickier about what they buy
they don't buy as many movies uh in the
u.s
you know you don't have video stores
really anymore and you don't have as
many places to sell movies except online
so a lot of that infrastructure is just
not there anymore
you know what you have in place is
amazon and you know you've got sales
through some sites and then you've got
streaming well streaming is a poor
replacement
for especially in monetary terms it's
definitely a poor placement for
foreign sales and video stores rentals
and sales
you know it's just not it's just not the
same thing i mean
you do not make you make very very
little on each
view each turn that a movie makes
on a streaming site especially after the
distributor has recouped costs and
everything but even it's not even
about that it just nobody makes a lot on
those turns
you know everybody's got all these
because these
chains whether it's amazon or it's
itunes or it's walmart
i mean they're dictating the terms now
used to be the only one you had to worry
about dictating terms
so much was blockbuster well they're
gone now but now
everybody's dictating terms and
everybody's got their hand in and
everybody's charging against things and
um you know it's so it's very difficult
it's not what it used to be
you have to find unique ways to get your
movie out there get in front of people
and make them want to buy it
one thing that we we didn't really do
this in a
it wasn't really planned but just we
worked well for the project our last two
movies for example have come out on vhs
now some people could say why in the
world do you want to put a movie on vhs
they don't make that anymore for
13 14 years now well because there are
collectors
who collect especially horror vhs
and they are interested in vhs releases
of certain
new horror movies not all of them but
certain ones especially because we have
a retro thing going for us with retro
directors who've
had movies released on vhs back in the
day so
we've got kind of a cool retro kind of
like vinyl it's sort of the the
movie equivalent of vinyl it's cool it's
it's practically maybe it doesn't make a
whole lot of sense but it's a cool
collectible
it has different artwork on it um you
know
it's some of their limited editions so
you know there's only so many that are
gonna
get made and it's just you know cool to
put on the shelf and especially if
you're a fan of a certain director's
work or you just like independent horror
movies
so that's one of the ways we've you know
kind of been able to skin the cat
in that respect it's but it's very
difficult you know we're also you know
putting movies on blu-ray we're starting
you know we get some sales off of that
some people are very
uh once again collectors for the
opposite of the spectrum
blu-ray collectors who want everything
on blu-ray dvd's almost like
in the middle you know we do that too
but but blu-ray and vhs have unique
collectibility
but those are you know we're always
trying to find new ways to kind of
get the movie in front of people and
thankfully there are more festivals now
than there used to be
there's more public screening
opportunities than there used to be
and so that's a great way to build buzz
for your movie and get the word out and
get people excited about it and things
like that we've been doing a lot of that
uh kind of the grassroots because these
are very grassroots films they're
they're
we supervise them here in la and you
know we shoot part of it here in la
but they're shot all over the country so
there's a lot of support
actually more more than there is here i
would say there's a lot of support for
horror in other states other parts of
the u.s
you know and people do drive we've had
drive-in screenings for our movies
we've had you know all kinds of cool you
know things like that and not and not
only here but in
in europe also but you know i think that
there's not as many places to physically
get movies from anymore but there are
more ways to
people are almost opening up more
avenues to screen them and have public
screenings and outdoor screenings and
stuff like that
so so you know but but yeah it's it's
you know i'll tell you though at the
same time distribution has gotten harder
but in making money off of it has
definitely gotten harder
but it's really never been easy and
if you're in it for that alone and
you're and you're focusing only on that
then you're probably in the wrong
business you know
um there's there has to be more to it
than your you know you there has to be
more to it in terms of why you're doing
it
than just for that but yeah i've seen a
lot of changes in
in the distribution over the years for
sure
and with theatrical do you just do like
a one night
screening for casting crew and then you
don't really use that as your model
we've done things like that yeah
we've done like you know kind of like
four walling or or find a cool venue
you know that's that's open to to indie
film like we found a cool venue
around here called zebulon it's like in
frog town it's like a music venue that
does movie screenings too
and they love film and they have great
audio great you know um
great acoustics and and the screen and
everything so we did our premiere over
there
um rocktown sorry yeah i don't know i'm
sorry
to that like los feliz area
okay sorry okay yeah yeah frogtown oh my
gosh i've been here for 20 plus years
well frank you know it's it's always
been there it just
it's more in the press now than it used
to be it's not like it's
there were years where i didn't you know
anyway but that's where we did our thing
okay yeah we'll try and then yeah the
other filmmakers will do local premieres
too
because we've got you know let's say
four or five other directors
they'll do local premieres they'll do
different things so it's that's one of
the cool things about these
these anthology films too is that they
create
you can almost create like a web that
expands beyond the la base you can kind
of go
you know you can have screens in new
jersey you can have screenings in
kentucky you can have screening
you know different places because
everybody's got
connections to different venues where
they live
and you know where they work so
and that's what a lot of people are
doing nowadays they're just trying to
find
interesting angles to approach
distribution and you know
getting the word out for your movie
okay let's say we're going to go back to
your high school virginia beach
and you are going to have a five-minute
pow-wow with some students
on the first steps of making a movie
what would you tell them
when i was making shorts with my friends
when i was 17 18. i was having fun
i mean it was work but it didn't you
don't think of it that way nobody did i
don't think
so you should have fun and you should
you know think of an idea or something
that you
mean something to you personally that's
that's different not just
uh you know because a lot of young
filmmakers they just imitate
other movies that they've seen they do
their own version of that and i did
things like that too
but i think if you're gonna like really
put some effort into something nowadays
you know maybe try to think of an idea a
storyline a little short story
that you know
has some kind of meaning to you
personally it isn't to be the most like
biggest heavy theme in the world but
just something that means something to
you
and also try to do something simple and
start off with something simple
because if you try to do a bigger thing
right off the bat it's it's gonna
you know it could turn into a mess so i
think you know and usually the really
the really good short films
the best ones i'm talking about the top
of the you know they're usually fairly
simple with a lot not too many
characters and a fairly straightforward
story and some kind of a surprise at the
end some kind of a twist at the end
you know that kind of stays in your mind
so those are some of the things i would
say i mean i just think you but i think
you should have fun doing it i think
that's that's very important don't worry
too much about the technical aspect of
it
i think you know you you will learn that
over time if you're serious about it if
you're in
and you might even have other people
doing those those jobs
but initially i think you should just
think more about
conveying something original you know
idea-wise i would say and then would it
be the same if it was for features let's
say you're
speaking to a group of high school
students who've been making short films
since they were like eight
and so now they're ready to make this
leap would be the same
or any other advice jeez you know it's
it's funny i mean like the first feature
i did i was 17 when i directed
it was a vampire hitman movie
called bad blood and it was just so
influenced by you know
john woo the killer and you know
probably some horror movies i was
watching at the time and
so it wasn't the most original thing in
the world uh and it was biting
we were definitely biting off a lot more
than we could chew we had all these big
action scenes and effects and stuff so
it would be tough for me to tell people
don't do that you know like it'd be
tough for me to tell people don't be
ambitious
with your future because i don't know i
feel like a lot of the a lot of
major filmmakers who start off making
shorts and things like that they were
pretty ambitious with their projects
so i don't know i mean i think you i
think it does just boil down like the
short film it kind of boils down to
coming up with an idea that you're
really passionate about and a story
you're really passionate about
and something you feel realistically you
can achieve
you know with your resources that you
have but it's always good to push a
little bit more beyond that
like i still do that now like anytime i
come up with an idea for something i
want to make
i always think to myself okay what are
we what resources do we have
okay great now let's push another 10
another 20
percent how much 30 however much percent
we can push it
because i feel like if you're not doing
that then
you're not challenging yourself enough
you're not like
that's to me that's the excitement is
always pushing beyond a bit beyond your
budget beyond your
resources because then you come up with
cool
creative things sometimes like cool
creative
solutions for those things do you know
what i mean
that's that's what i would say
interesting because do you think
has it always been been in you to not
play it safe or were you always groomed
to play it safe
i might have been groomed to play it
safe but i don't think i did
i mean i mean if i did i wouldn't make
any movies i wouldn't
pick up a camera and even bother with it
and because these things were definitely
not safe i mean sometimes there were
literal safety issues you know with
we're you know trying to do gun fights
and we're setting off
firecrackers you know using firecrackers
as squibs and
you know we we we got you know taken
home by the cops more than a few times
you know
we're filming these things and kicked
out of locations and
we didn't get arrested or booked but
just
close to that as close as you can get to
that
so no i was definitely not playing it
safe and i and i've always had this in
you know mentality and sometimes it's
got me into trouble
where i'll go into something that's very
low budget and in my mind
is some big 100 million dollar movie
like my mind you know i'm making a movie
for a million dollar movie and my mind
is like aliens
you know or something that's 100 million
why can't we just do that why can't we
just do that stuff well because we're on
the money
i don't want to hear that i just want to
try to do something with that level of
intensity and
and everything so it's it's uh i've
always kind of been like that i always
kind of
push beyond the boundaries i think in
terms of the the resources
and stuff um that's that's the fun of it
you know i think going back to paul
schrader i know we were just having fun
talking about it off camera but
you were just you had something to say
about just his work and being
appreciated
well i think what okay i'm a huge paul
schrader fan
i've been a fan since i discovered his
work while i was in film school
and i'm a fan of not just the movies
he's written but the movies he's
directed which are the ones that people
i think really need to see
the uh first reformed he got his first
oscar nomination for first reformed
this past you know uh oscars and he
didn't win but
i was number one surprised that that was
the first oscar nomination he'd ever
received for
considering he's written you know movies
like taxi driver and raging bull i was
i was i consider my straight myself a
straighter expert and i thought he had
at least been nominated for those movies
my
point though where i was thinking you
know was this
thing about first reform which is on a
lot of critics top 10 lists and all that
is you never you never really count
anybody out
you know paul schroeder is someone who i
think has been counted out
more than once in his career i think
he's been
i don't say the butt of jokes but i
think he's definitely been you know
downgraded not really appreciated as a
filmmaker
and even recently especially with some
of the stuff that he
directed and i think it's just great
that
he made that film it's very much of a
schrader film it's very pure schrader
movie and even if i didn't like it as
much as some of his other work i still
just was so happy to see that and i
think it just proves that nobody's ever
out you know no filmmaker is ever
retired
or done because you never know what they
might come up with next
so that's what i yeah that's really what
i thought i mean and other people did
too
you know and when you had friends that
went to film school
that kind of said like i wouldn't do
that or don't do that or that's stupid
or why would you
do was that sort of in your mind just
seeing how
someone's work or someone can be doubted
at first and underappreciated do you
think you
i think i've i think i've reached the
point because i've been directing
now for 20 plus years
i've reached the point that you know
i've had my own ups and downs
just like a lot of other filmmakers and
it puts you it gives you a perspective
on things
and you you are more you you are more
understanding of those type of like ups
and downs and shifts that every
filmmaker has in their career
so like the thing with schrader you know
to me it was just sort of like a nice
proof it happens with actors a lot
sometimes but you don't see it as much
with like
directors or writers you know sometimes
you'll you know what i mean that kind of
that kind of thing that kind of rebirth
or that kind of revitalized thing
sometimes you'll you know see that but
um
no i don't know i just i just think that
i'm not
i'm not regretful of any anything you
know what i mean
i think people it's these are people to
make fun of stuff sometimes when they're
you know they're not doing it or
whatever it's always easier it's always
easier to not make a movie than to make
a movie
you know and it's interesting how the
crowd turns
can turn on somebody who can have like
three great movies in a row and man they
do one movie it's not even that it's
like
a beautiful subject matter and then
people oh i'm so angry about two of my
two of my favorite directors
william fritkin peter boganovic that's
exactly what happened to both of them
i mean freaking on the even bigger level
because he had you know
french connection the exorcist and you
know you don't get bigger and more
popular than those films
uh then he did sorcerer which everyone
just loved to hate
even though it's not a bad film in fact
i think it's his best film
and a lot of people have come around and
he considers it his best film too
by the way a lot of people consider that
his best work or definitely one of his
best movies
and i think people are just looking for
him to fail
like they're kind of wanting him to fail
at that point like okay buddy you've had
your turn
you're done now you know that's that's
that's how i perceived it
bogdanovic is the same with you know uh
with the last picture show and what's up
doc and all that and then he
you know kind of couldn't wait to sort
of you know have this big downward
and i'm not look i'm not saying that all
everything you know all these
everything they directed was brilliant
but
there's this there is a tendency yeah to
kind of like put somebody way up on a
pedestal and then tear them down
way down way way lower than they
than they deserve you know yeah it seems
like that's part of almost
some career paths and then there's a
rebuilding and a rebirth
yeah like years later different people i
mean like you know like i was mentioning
friedkin he's another one that you know
he's some of the films he's made lately
and i think he's in his 80s now
or late 70s or 80s or some of his best
films
i mean i thought bug was a tremendous
movie and it's a very small movie you
know
and and i thought killer joe was really
good and these are like recent films
that he directed
and he's had a lot of peaks and valleys
i actually find filmmakers like that a
lot
more interesting than like directors
like sorry but people like spielberg
who are pretty much coasting along and
yeah sure he's got some ups and downs
but like
he's never been vilified the way some of
these
other filmmakers were talking about and
you know he's never had probably such
box office
you know losses and you know incredible
he's never worked on such a small level
either like a movie like bug or um
or killer joe or something like that you
know so
i just i find directors like that more
interesting i think a lot of my favorite
filmmakers are
kind of eccentric and they're not
mainstream
necessarily very few actually are
you know let's suppose you were going to
retire from filmmaking
and you would never make another movie
again
you'd have one month to plan out this
retirement this exit from filmmaking
how would you spend that last month what
would you be doing
it would be your last month to ever
think about
making a movie i mean it's simply just
the obvious answer but i would
i would probably want to get i would
want to shoot
the film that we're planning right now i
mean it's because it's in my mind right
now
that we're doing for this next film for
this next anthology film
because it's written and it's in
pre-production right now
so we might we might be able to do it in
a month
and if i didn't make that i'd probably
go out to the desert and make some kind
of improv
road movie of some kind because that's
something i really love and i love that
environment i love those type of films
and i just probably
grab some actors some people who seem
cool and just
go out there and do like a rain people
or tulane blacktop type
film just driving around the salton sea
or something like that and just
you know just make that my big finale
you know um that's that's the first
thing that comes to me
so you wouldn't overthink it because you
wouldn't have time i wouldn't want to no
i wouldn't want to overthink it i've had
so many films where i
had like almost no prep or crazy prep
and i just went and did it and
things were happening all around me and
i'm like reacting to these circumstances
so i'm not afraid to do that in fact
the thing i like about the films we've
done lately is that there is an
aspect of playfulness about them
where you don't overthink too much
and you feel like you're going back to
your roots
so i'm still in that mode i'm glad to be
in that mode
because i was in a another kind of mode
for a while
and it's fun to just sort of being more
in a mode where you feel like there's no
safety net
and you're just you know
making something you're passionate about
and you're not that worried about what
people are going to think about it
or like it or don't like it or it's
going to sell this territory or that
territory
and you're just you're just out there
doing it so i'd have no problem doing
that i would spend the whole month
shooting that movie the longest schedule
i ever had
you just grabbed like a couple actors a
car yeah
yeah and that's kind of what we did like
when we did this this short called the
scout for high eight
i always just wanted to shoot was based
on location i thought location was first
a lot of times location is very very
important in the movie for me movies i
like and the movies i make
and i'm like that it's going to be in
the desert there'll be two people
guy and a girl and we'll figure out what
the story is going to be it's going to
end badly
and that's it you know when we figured
out the script
so i have no problem doing something
like that i've always been inspired by
the rain people that coppola film where
he took james khan and
duvall and shirley knight out on the
road and they just literally
traveled with them through the united
states through a bunch of different
states and they
they had some kind of a script but they
responded to
things that were going on in the
environments the different towns they
went through and that found its way into
the film i've always thought that was a
cool
such a cool model to make a movie on and
it's
you know so i would i would love to do
something like that
plus you coming to la was its own road
trip
yeah it was and i wrote a treatment for
a
back then right when i first moved out
here i actually wrote a treatment for a
youth oriented kids coming to la to make
it
a movie called the open road and you
know i
messed around with that for a while i
never wrote the screenplay but i did
have it i still have the treatment for
it
i don't know if i'd want to make that or
make something different but i've
i've always wanted to do those type of
things before i got involved in the
whole horror scene
the scripts i was writing were not
horror movies they you know
might have had weird or dark elements
but they weren't horror films
so i'd like to see that
now it might happen stranger things have
happened
you know a lot of people have had the
moving to l.a in their car
and yeah that's what it was it's like a
group of friends
and based on people i knew other
transplants i knew when i first moved
here they were also from virginia but
they didn't come here with me
i just started it was weird i would
start meeting people who are from
virginia
some of them been out here for a little
while some of them had been here or just
got here on the same time i did
and a few of them are even from virginia
beach and
so like i had a dp i worked with for
years who was from virginia and
and these actors and they're all the
people i worked with in my early films
like in my first three or four
movies you know so
i based those character characters in
the treatment on them back then
and uh does it have a happy ending that
that first
i'm trying to remember how that in i
don't remember how that treatment ends
but probably not knowing me
everybody dies in a hail of gunfire or
something
while going to like an audition i think
they i think they separate i think they
all kind of go their separate past which
frankly is how it goes in real life to
be honest i mean it's that's
that's actually realistically how how
life is
so without knowing that
really i was writing about something i
didn't really know a lot about
but it did that that is kind of how it
how it goes
do they still keep in touch um
not really some some people are just
like
i kind of know about them but i don't
really talk to them anymore and some i
don't know where what happened to them
like they might as well fall off the
face of the earth like
no digital footprint no nothing yeah
i mean and things like that happen and
it it's not like you of course the
normal response is to think maybe it's
did i say something did it something i
did no it's not
people have everybody's got their own
inner thing going on that you don't even
know about no matter how well you know
them
and there's this business can do strange
things to people
people's minds sometimes so
you have to contend with that
and sort of make peace with that you
know as you
you know continue
i still want to see the movie now i hope
you make it when i dig up the script
i've probably got it somewhere i think i
might have typed it up i used to hand
write everything
i i didn't start typing my scripts up
until like
i didn't use even use final draft until
like movie number five or six i used to
even type them literally and like
move you know i don't think anyone wants
to hear this but
i used to you know really bump the
cursor i mean that was ridiculous in
word
you know but i used to handwrite
everything for a long time for years and
years everything would be handwritten
first then typed up
but i don't do that i know there's some
writers that do that i think tarantino
does that i think i read
he still doesn't see yeah okay i think
it's cool when people do that i just
i just personally don't have the luxury
i can't yeah my hand starts to cramp up
yeah my hand starts to cramp up after a
while
yeah but i but i did used to hand write
every like my first two features i know
or first three or four really five maybe
they were all handwritten then typed up
and then some producers some guy i was
working for he hired me to write a
script for a movie that didn't get
produced but anyway i wrote the script
and he bought fi he had final draft like
he got me final draft as part of the
deal
because he had a line on software so i
was like great you know so then i
after that it was final draft um
not that i think that's that interesting
but it was a transition for me
at that time to you know kind of and
that's i've never looked back
you know i never hand written
script ever again why but that open road
one might be
the open road was see i did a video
feature of my friends in high school
that's two and a half hours long and
that's a road movie
a post-apocalyptic road movie so that
title was in my mind for a long time but
i'm not going to get into that
you don't have any more memory cards
it's hot in here
everybody wants to go home